los asistentes están en modo de sólo escucha qué tal muy buenas tardes lo que se me oye pero
como siempre voy a poner por aquí para que me confirméis si alguien no me escucha que
me no escriba una tarda a ver que no veo mi cam no sé dónde está está compartida pero no la veo aquí
aquí detrás aquí detrás total para lo que hay que ver vamos allá novena clase como siempre me
doy un paseo por el disc or a ver un poquito las las preguntas en rick no sé si estás en el
directo tenemos un email que ahora alberto te lo está mirando disculpa nos lo enviaste creo que el
sábado y todavía no te lo hemos respondido como los envía por email pues entiendo a priori que
lo contestamos por por email no para respetar pues tu canal digamos no luego habían algunas
cosas esta de Juan Manuel no la he leído aún no sé que la voy a leer del tirón de resto si que
lo había ya lo había ya mirado hoy por lo fácil carlos preguntaba por un artículo de 5 de febrero
pues lo miramos lo tengo pendiente porque no sabe hasta ahora última hora la clase de hoy ya veréis
que es bastante bastante tensa no sé si decir tensa o profunda técnica veréis que hemos está
muy trabajada y de hecho es información como ya os dije que sí que hay que darle una vuelta más
más que nada porque porque la velocidad de hacerlo pues pues te genera esa duda esa cierta
duda pero pero vaya que principio está está probablemente hecho y seguramente las decisiones
que os voy a decir son las que haremos en la realidad es decir esto es esto pero le haremos
una vuelta antes porque es verdad que ha habido una cierta prisa para llegar a la clase y acabarlo
todo lo que os queríamos enseñar o no para para que tuviera valor para vosotros y entonces
pues le daremos esta vuelta pero vaya principio yo creo que sí que será vale entonces ya digo
te lo miramos lo del 5 de febrero que comentas me voy para para arriba esto ya estaba todo esto
es prácticamente mucho del 11 de marzo no estaba del 11 de marzo a lo que fue del mismo día creo
pero sí sí no sí sí sí sí se le contesté se era contesté sobre el tos y no lo enmarqué
de una mar que vaya yo creo que esa contestada si sí es que no me lo dices pero se canse
uno al seguro que le contesté a Juan Manuel si es que no me lo me lo dices Juan Manuel yo
tengo este clip este clic que es mi marca para decir ya está vale esa barca que ha hecho para
que ya está no lo tenía puesto pero ellos que seguro que sí que le contesté a Juan Manuel si
es que no no sé si está Juan Manuel a ver si está no no no sé ahora me escribes
si no si está no está si lo de los etf es creo que también de contesté de
contesté a senen que hay que hacer no se puede que hay que hacerlo si se me
acuerdo que luego que lo contesté también ya pues vamos con esta nueva
pues tenía una más que entiende la verdad a bueno esto comentas en el del
error vale estas muy quería comentar un par de cosas aquí muy muy
interesantes pero espera espera que voy que tenía estas también este van que es
que teoría me la no pasa nada no pasa nada verá por organización pero es
verdad tenemos que las pongáis aquí pero creamos este no sé por qué
y bueno vais poniendo a veces a veces aquí vale esto del trade yo creo que ya
quedó ya quedó resuelto el bowling herbans por el bowling herbans solo a
bruto me resulta estoy leyendo aquí este van hay que hablaba de que iba atrasado
entiendo del bowling herbans que hablamos en la teórica con la salida
exit only es complicado que sólo bowling herbans así te rente es
complicado te faltan comisiones es hay muchos trade bueno no cero no en todo
caso no sería operable pero pero bueno no es mal comienzo tampoco hay que decir
que es lo que es lo que tú decías ahí bueno para para punto de partida
seguramente no no es malo no podías empeorar el beneficio para bajar el
riesgo lo que no sé exactamente lo que me
preguntas si dices quería entender que se puede tener opciones metiéndole más
variables a lo que tengo en el mini sp si es esa con ese criterio estoy de
acuerdo es decir un setup que lo pones te da 109 con 9000 operaciones estoy de
acuerdo eso de acuerdo que es un setup prometedor vale decir para seguir de
acuerdo pero bueno habría que mirar lógicamente más cosas como bien dices
no hay variables estoy de acuerdo estoy de acuerdo en que probablemente es
bueno el bowling herbans es una muy buena señal ya lo comenté en la teoría y
tengo pensado lo que pasa que no sé yo creo que en algún en algún momento no
sé dónde va a ser el límite pero en algún momento tendré que decidir no
hacer todo lo que quería hacer porque lo que estoy viendo es que si a otro que
tenía que hacer será un curso de 500 horas en práctica entonces no no no puede
ser no puede ser entonces en algún momento habrá que ir ya diciendo bueno
esto no esto sí porque va a ser imposible es imposible es ya os lo
comenté queríamos sobre la marcha y que tenía intención de hacerlo todo pero
cada vez tengo más dudas de conseguirlo sinceramente porque ya llevamos muchas
horas siguen quedando muchas de tranquilos y en quedando muchas pero es
que aún quedando muchas no creo que haga todo lo que quiero hacer de verdad
entonces
sigo lo que comentaba de ese nen hay una cosa muy interesante que ha comentado
primero lo del back no lo hemos mirado porque adego la preparación de la clase
nos ha llevado muchísimas muchísimas horas
la de hoy aquí tenemos que mirarlo tenemos que mirarlo pero bueno si dices
que sí seguramente estará mal hay que hay que mirarlo ya lo ya ya lo hemos
comentado de mirarlo vale luego otra cosa en el código hay dos líneas
para que no ver la posición y cerrar el instante el objetivo de profit vale
entiendo para que son pero tenía pensado que estaba que easy language estaba
diseñado para impedir leer datos a futuros si así es y el pregunta no
existe otra manera de lanzar órdenes condicionados por ejecución en un rango
de precios bien si claro hay otra manera otras maneras de hacerlo y hay veces que
no se puede utilizar open nextbar por distintos motivos por ejemplo tener dos
datas o algún otro factor pero muy muy importante en open of next bar no lea
futuro vale es muy importante entender bien esto esto no es leer a futuro lo
que hacen open of next bar no deja de ser un truco de lenguaje en el que lo que
hace es al cierre de la vela en cuestión el retrasa el cierre vale a el
tick de apertura simplemente no es que lea futuro es que espera al tick de
apertura para leer el código de acuerdo y lee tres datos esto
en el mastering seguro ahora dudo si sale en el inicial te acuerdas albertos
salen inicial salen más en el mastering sale en el mastering sale en el más en
la clase de más se trata porque eso es normal es algo que no tiene todos los
lenguajes es un caso es una utilidad bastante interesante pero no siempre se
puede usar pero pero hay veces que sí viene bien porque lo que hace es leer del
tick de apertura tres datos el precio de apertura la hora y la fecha sólo esos
tres datos entonces tú puedes usar esos tres datos del tick de apertura para
procesarlo en la barra de cierre del día anterior pero del día de la barra
anterior entonces no lea futuro simplemente espera procesarlo por lo
tanto yo ahí lo que hago es llamar al open of next bar y le digo si el open of
next bar es menor que tanto hace x cosa pero no lea futuro se entiende espera
ese tick sólo es leer a futuro leer a futuro es usar un dato que no dispones
de él en el momento de en el momento de ejecutar el código aquí sí que le
dispone por eso se espera entonces espera lo lee y entonces ejecuta la regla
que tú le digas de acuerdo así que es perfectamente útil y en este caso
simplemente es para decir oye si hay un gap que supera el precio que yo tengo
pensado ya cerrar para que voy a abrir entonces le pregunto oye has abierto por
encima de tal precio me dice sí pues no no tienes la orden entonces no atires
ya está esta mañana tienes un poco eso o para otras cosas se puede usar pero
para sistemas de gaps va fantástico claro para sistemas de gaps es fantástico
pero insisto decía no se puede usar en dos datos por ejemplo
entonces espero que haya quedado claro esto
luego aquí lo comentaba con manuel lo leo que esto no lo he leído ahora del
tirón tenía un par de cuestiones con manuel dice que tras ver un vídeo en
youtube se mostraba una función de easy language con 500 filtros no son pocos me
surgió una duda tomando como ejemplo listado en él de entradas y salidas que
se controlaba mediante inputs mostraba la teoría me preguntaba si haciendo lo
mismo con un listado de filtros intentar optimizar todos mediante su input para
ver cuál funcionaría mejor si esto es una buena práctica o es sobre optimizar
es decir se busca qué filtro de un listado predeterminado va mejor para el
sistema atendiendo a su óptima para luego quedarnos con el mejor
bien muy buena pregunta Juan Manuel bueno acabo acabo de leer porque así
igual es todo todo en una no dice luego que sobre los filtros a la hora de
elegir alguno en caso de que así sea tenéis algún listado estándar o varios
que por consenso uséis generalmente o los filtros elegís según vuestro
criterio o ideas personales en el momento es decir en qué basarse para elegir qué
tipo de filtro usar a la gran diversidad de estos que hay vale bien filtros lo
que comentas de usar
usar un optimizador de filtros si puede hacerse si puede hacerse y de hechos
puede ser buena práctica puede ser buena práctica y no tiene por qué ser sobre
optimizar vale pero debería de estar todo bastante acotado es decir no no
optimicemos ya el filtro también es decir si el filtro depende de un
parámetro de volatilidad encima no optimicemos el parámetro de acuerdo
decir optimicemos el filtro en un parámetro estándar o sea probemos ese
filtro en un parámetro estándar otro en otro parámetro estándar de acuerdo y
lógicamente como siempre como cualquier regla pues habrá que ver el tema de
significación estadística etcétera etcétera no es el número de tres que
tenemos y podríamos hacer alguna otra prueba de evaluación como z-score o
cualquiera de estas no pero se puede hacer se puede se puede hacer esto no
deja de ser un un builder y por eso yo y de hecho en el debate interno es en
algún momento usar algún algún builder para hacer algo de esto porque esto al
final es un no deja de ser un builder implementado en ese lenguaje por cierto
el código es de 500 filtros si no nos quieres pasar sería interesante verlo yo
lo no sé cuál te refieres yo no lo he visto lo tiene lo tiene visto ya son ya
son filtros y 500 entonces pero ya digo en general si no sé si 500 500 pero al
final esto es un builder implementado en código un builder externo como sabéis
builder que sé que nosotros tenemos comprado hace muchos años se puede
usar pero se puede usar ya teniéndolo muy cerrado de acuerdo es decir el
problema de los builders es dejarlos buscar libremente silenciado sonido
reactivado alguien me ha silenciado ya está vale
y la me ha silenciado nada hoy en pilar si quieres que me calle yo nada se ha
equivocado me había silenciado nada no y esto no pasa nada
si lo dejamos para otro día bueno nada nada seguimos entonces
ya digo esto por ejemplo hecho en un builder no sería mala práctica
no sería mala práctica pero quiere decir que tú ya tienes tu setup de entrada
de salida y tratas de buscar filtro para mejorar la entrada entiendo lo que
estamos hablando puede ser buena práctica pero como con todo hace falta
buen criterio y un buen filtro debe quitar malas más malas que buenas hay
que ver hay que ver una vez siempre cuando comparas filtro es que como va el
sistema antes de filtrado filtrado de ver un poco los parámetros clave proteger
ciertos beneficio medio de positivas y negativas número de positivos número
negativos es lo típico porque ahí lo que busca un filtro es quitar malos
estamos de acuerdo no es decir busca quitar malos pero hombre si sólo quita
malos es un poco sospechoso también tiene que quitar más malos que buenos
pero algún bueno también tiene que quitar si sólo se quita malos entonces
a cuál a cuál filtro elegir bueno no tenemos una lista porque nosotros no
hemos sido nunca muy amantes de los filtros eso es verdad hemos filtrado
poco por esa como sabéis siempre prudencia estadística que tenemos donde
siempre tratamos nos pesa mucho la significación estadística y filtrar es
perder trades eso es obvio pero siempre nos ha nos ha costado o dicho de otra
manera los filtros no acaba de mandar han acabado de aportar mucho o lo
suficiente para aplicarlo no pero al final más o menos si podemos en algún
momento si queréis tratar de tratar de dar algunas referencias con el urb por
ejemplo ya lo dimos y a medida que vamos iremos hablando de sistemas de lo iremos
dando pero lógicamente a cada tipo de sistema lo vamos mando pero al final
no no me complicaría en demasiada vida me explico es decir porque entonces sí
que 500 filtros me parece una locura no me complicaría en exceso la vida y si
tenemos que complicarla tanto seguramente ya es que el sistema no no no vale si
tienes que filtrar tanto y buscarle tantos filtros mejor busca otro sistema
entiendes entonces filtros que hay al final pues las cosas obvias una cosa que
hemos hablado hasta la saciedad la volatilidad en casi todos casi todos los
tipos de sistema suele ir bien filtrar o puede ser una cosa a evaluar de acuerdo
filtrar volatilidad y desde ahí cuidado puede ser vía a tierra interna vía
externa vía vix por ejemplo también hay de este tipo en intermarkets con por
ejemplo la curva del vix es decir los distintos periodos de eso quería es una
de las cosas que tengo apuntadas ver pero es bastante avanzada y si lo vemos lo
veremos de lo último de acuerdo porque es una cosa bastante bastante avanzada
pero tiene que haber filtro es un filtro volatilidad pero poco externo vale un poco
externo con las con los 600 vencimientos del vix que más luego lógicamente el
régimen de mercado no lo que técnicamente se llama régimen de mercado
que podemos simplificar que recordaréis seis volatilidad a la baja volatilidad a
la alza tendencia cista tendencia bajista y neutral no en ambos casos pues
esa mezcla de todo pues se puede dar seis no nueve es al final es un poco
porque puedes hacer alta subiendo alta bajando baja subiendo baja bajando por
ejemplo pero pero bueno en los dos vectores principales siempre son
volatilidad y tendencia y eso al final te da un régimen de mercado de acuerdo
entonces ahí pues hay muchos regimen de mercado desde los más sencillos con una
media móvil hasta los más complejos con confinientes de justo o sea al final
hay muchas cosas a mirar pero repito no yo soy muy amante de la simplicidad como
sabéis y y por lo tanto eso aplica a todo también a los filtros como en el
también a los filtros vale espero espero haberte ayudado y vamos allá vamos allá
con la clase de hoy que podríamos titular hoy que ya avancé como la
revisión de apolo short vale la revisión de apolo short donde empezamos
voy a empezar ocultando esto bien apolo es un sistema que está hoy en día
operando es un sistema que opera largo y corto pero que de hace bastante tiempo
que al principio no era así se decidió hacer
se dio a hacer el determinado momento se decidió probar si aportaba valor
hacerlo como ya sospechábamos pero al principio operaba con el mismo set en el
largo y en el corto algo que hay autores que recomiendan y que en sí es verdad
que puede ser una buena práctica pero que no necesariamente no hacerlo es mala
se entiende es decir es decir es preferible puede serlo pero
sobre todo en equity normalmente hay especialistas de cortos especialistas de
largos porque por lo de la volatilidad que os decía realmente y por la dinámica
propia del mercado donde el régimen de mercado es muy alcista y por lo tanto es
distinto es decir el normalmente el largo deja correr quiere correr en cambio el
corto pues no quiere correr al final corto es un sistema más de oportunidad
rápida es lo que es bastante obvio es bastante obvio pues bueno bastante obvio
pues por esto no por esto porque aquí sólo he cargado un periodo de bueno si
cargo mira puedo cargar un workspace de largo plazo que tengo por ahí
vuelvo aquí sí porque como hay muchos perfiles pues siempre pues estoy por
hechas muchas cosas perdonarme bueno pues porque pues esto de acuerdo por esto
porque digamos que el sesgo de largo plazo es ligeramente alcista no
ligeramente ligeramente alcista viento de cola no claro que hay periodos que
pueden ser de muchos años de lateral de corrección o congestión etcétera hay
muchas muchas variedades no pero en el largo plazo pues es más bien tendente a
subir por lo tanto ya añade un sesgo distinto distinto no vale entonces bien
apolo apolo opera ya hace tiempo con parámetros para corto parámetros para
largo y hay distintos sets dentro del mismo del mismo sistema en este caso
bueno el mismo set opera con distintos es sistema vale vale lo miro lo miro venga
esperas es que a menos sí sí pero es server este server es server pero bueno
vale no es el del nuevo vale vale pero me vale vale vale no es que es que
hemos hecho a no sé si lo comenté estoy abierto si lo comenté la clase lo
comenté en el en el directo de hecho hemos hecho un pequeño cambio en apolo
que no es de las revisiones que hay pendientes de cosas de evoluciones sino
una simplificación de del código que implica al final de quitarle un input y
de hecho os lo digo abiertamente en este caso este sistema usa el atr de
acuerdo y la tr en algunas épocas ha utilizado y ahora ya hace un tiempo que
no recuerdo que no se optimiza y está fijo el acuerdo está fijo en creo que
está fijo en 15 y en 15 barras porque en su momento pues ya se hizo un estudio
muy exhaustivo y se ha revisado hace poco y es una zona que está bastante
estabilizada con mapa que luego veremos mapas y demás y por lo tanto pues nos
gusta que esté que esté ahí vale entonces lo que os digo tiene largo y
corto bien el corto lleva a una época mala y que en algunos seds se ha
convertido en demasiado mala vale entonces el demasiado mala se ha ido
degradando porque este el sistema de cortos sistema de largos ya digo tiene
distinto tipo pero como veis en general veis que este este set aquí de tp por
ejemplo es un tp bastante podemos decir ahora un update no después me equivocaba
de botón esto lo que yo quería es por ejemplo este este trade
es este tren por ejemplo no se trae de tres o cuatro días que hace un tp
bastante interesante interesante en cambio los tps a ver si hay alguno aquí
aquí hay algún tp caros los tps del corto es que es otra cosa es de muy poco
recorrido esto es lo que busca el corto corto tiene un tp siempre más cercano y
os lo comentaba varias veces la teoría también la práctica y cierta manera
pensando en apolo es decir realmente una de las mejores maneras de bajar el
riesgo es tener un tp cercano de acuerdo es decir en datos de riesgo del
lo baja mucho porque sale sale rápido y de hecho apolo trabaja con esto en el
lado corto mayor que tp vale es un es un esto que salta pocas veces y ese es su
problema que en los sets que van hay sets que dejan correr un poco más hay
se ha hecho un poco más parecidos a el largo no tanto pero hay algún set más
parecido y hay sets de como este de la derecha que veis que es muy muy rápido
acuerdo que hace tp muy rápido entonces cuando tiene 2 3 4 fallos pues y son un
poco fallos de cierta importancia como alguno que veis aquí pues bueno pues
pues duele más entonces a lo que a lo que vamos donde empieza esto bueno esto
empieza con el protocolo de supervisión el protocolo de supervisión ya os lo
comenté en la en la en la teoría es algo en lo que tenemos campo de mejora ya
tenemos cosas hechas pero tenemos campo de mejora y de hecho pues mira una de
esas cosas que os comenté que en el curso nos puede servir a nosotros a ver
y aprovecharlo es esta de acuerdo es esta más que mejorar en darnos cuentas
en automatizarlo un poco porque es verdad que el protocolo de supervisión
lo puedes complicar todo lo que tú quieras pero ahora de la verdad no solo
pero normalmente si tú digo para vosotros de empezando que no os volváis
loco de acuerdo sobre todo aquellos que estáis empezando donde a digo dónde
está es que me lo está abriendo aquí arriba vale hay hay muchas maneras de hay
muchas maneras de hacer esto y mirando un performance report es una de ellas de
acuerdo mirando un performance report es una de ellas mirando la curva de draw
down la curva lógicamente del sistema los trades tú si vas aquí puedes ir a
buscar el trade más largo puedes a buscar el el peor trade el largue es
losing trade vale puedes ver cuando ha sido marzo el 16 etcétera de acuerdo
puedes puedes mirarlo una de esas maneras es esta lo cual tampoco penséis que
obligatoriamente hace falta tener un código y todo súper complicado pero bueno
sí que es verdad que una de las cosas que caracteriza la profesionalización es
esta automatizar más las cosas pero como al final aquellos que ya nos
conocéis no sólo de ahora del curso sino hace tiempo que habrá muchos que
son que es que están en este caso ya sabéis que me quejo siempre de la falta
de recursos y de tiempo es algo que es así porque al final todo esto lleva
trabajo y hay que decidir cuando eres una empresa un proyecto es igual tienes que
decidir en qué gastarse el tiempo los recursos y al final no es infinito igual
que no lo es el dinero tampoco lo es el tiempo y hay que decidir dónde dónde
haces cosas y por eso tenemos siempre una reunión mensual damos prioridad una
cosa otra y vas y hay cosas que están en las reuniones de hace años porque no
hay manera de que se considere que es prioritario respecto a otras cosas no y
esto hace que hayan cosas que a lo mejor podrían hacerse mejor pero ya se ya ya
te están bien así porque porque dedicarle un montón de horas a ello
pues no te renta no vale entonces aquí por ejemplo nosotros hoy en día sacamos
estos datos qué datos sacamos sacamos simplemente datos que ya veíais ahí en
el performance report pero que los sacamos vía el print de acuerdo que
esto es todo ya código este código ya me adelanto por si alguien lo pregunta
alberto no me ha autorizado a entregarlo todavía todavía pues es que
lo quiere lo quiere mejorar antes de entregarlo esto se llama orgullo de
programado entonces entonces yo yo yo entiendo yo entiendo que que antes
de acabar el curso ya os lo dijimos que lo haremos y lo haremos hoy os daremos
un código o esto y puede que algo mejor yo creo que ya está bastante bien pero
pero aberto dice que no que si me ocurra entregarlo ya quedó que lo quiere
mejorar entonces pero bueno al final informa del el mai el mayor drawdown
cuando lo hace cuando hace pelotero y cuando hace peor serie de tres de
acuerdo que son tres datos de riesgo bastante bastante importantes tenemos
uno que que hacemos en las revisiones más profundas vía excel ya os lo
comenté en las prácticas perdón la teoría y que ya creo que lo dije en la
teoría que teníamos planes es una de esas cosas que está pendiente a ver si
aprovechando lo acabamos de desarrollar que es lo de contar en e trades en e
trades vale pero no en valor absoluto sino en porcentaje acuerdo en porcentaje
porque en valor absoluto es muy complicado porque se desvirtúa este es
un poco el problema a veces hay que calcularlo en en porcentaje y a la que
acumula estrés eso ya no es tan fácil a nivel de histórico pero creo creo que
lo que lo conseguiremos entonces aquí ahora mismo pues vemos que este sistema
hizo drawdown record en octubre del 23 vale peor pero trade perdón y que su
drawdown record lo hizo histórico en 380 en mayo del 23 tras ese se revisó y
este ahora vuelve a estar cerca y ese set estando justo sigue estando sigue
estando operativo luego luego llegaremos a esto porque hoy veréis incluso se
enseñaremos los sets que cambiamos y toda la manera en que lo que lo
analizamos vale este este ser entiendo no recuerdo
pues el 3 igual no alberto este era vale vale pero si si yo creo que es el
pues que sea el 2 bueno luego como veremos veremos los los inputs pues ya
lo miraremos vale entonces en un momento en determinados salta salta salta la
alerta que ya nosotros ya veíamos que no que no iban finos de acuerdo es decir ya
lo ves es que la mayoría de veces esto tú ya lo ves pero lo cual no quita que
no vaya bien tener un código que te avise porque así pues puedes olvidarte
no pero pero tú ya lo ves la realidad es que esto es entonces bien vamos
el código ya digo ellos lo lo daremos si se si estos son distintos set
exactamente y sin dos set es distinta combinación de parámetros de la misma
estrategia si si corto esto apolo hace hace esto espérate que me mueva esto de
ventana bien pues entonces vamos con la revisión y que hacemos bueno hacemos
varias cosas la primera que hacemos es un mapa de optimización de
prácticamente o sino prácticamente todo el histórico vale todo el histórico
de tal forma a ver que lo abro mapa short este es todo parte lógicamente de
una de una optimización que la hacemos con out of sample detrás es decir cercano
del 25 porque mirando los cortes pues se ve que puede estar ahí interesante y
todo el histórico es por ello desde julio del 99 hasta el 29 de febrero del
2024 esto lo hacemos en datos de tic data que nosotros compramos pero podría
haberse hecho perfectamente en los datos de tres sesión con tres dólares de
comisión con ocho dólares de slippage pero no se hace de todos los inputs
no se hacen de todos los inputs los inputs que tiene el sistema son todos
estos no todos son optimizables los que le hemos dejado el nombre son del
algoritmo bueno este último es cuando hubo el halt en el covid tuvieron varios
halt y hubieron problemas de ejecución y entonces consideramos que ahí hay una
factor que ven que se benefició de manera artificial y lo penalizamos lo
penalizamos en 600 puntos ahí porque la ejecución no fue real eso puede pasar
probablemente pasa por un tic y el desempeje lo controla en este caso no
fue así el gráfico marcó ejecutado y ese día para que me entendáis y digo
porque esto
no te acordarás del día de memoria abierto no marzo de marzo 20 no a bueno
aquí no lo tengo no tengo cargado todo aquí lo tengo cargado todo y era el que salió
era el corto era la ropa bueno pero este si si abrió la baja si si eso es eso
acuerdo abrió menos siete de hecho que era el abrió un halt en el mercado
cerrado porque abre el sistema de los futuros americanos se abren en siete
cierran para estar obligado a parar debía ser aquí no esos pues aquí
imaginaros sé que era este trade que no recuerdo exactamente será este si tú
venías el largo
se fue aquí fue aquí bueno es igual imaginemos que fuera es que no veo ninguna
apertura muy bajista aquí no está está imagina imaginaros esta
ya sé que es un ejemplo para que me entendáis es esta vale imaginaros que
aquí se cierra una operación y como eso al final el optimizador también lo puede
tener en cuenta hay que tener pues el día siguiente ese no fue arriba en este
caso el 13 abrió arriba el 12 bueno igual era el 12 yo creo vale pues pues era
la apertura del nasdaq fue al alza el día 13 realmente además bueno es igual
lo que iba lo explico lo explico en este lo explico en este vale entonces
imaginaros que habría aquí pero realmente como el mercado es falso no
te deja ejecutar ejecuta 600 puntos por debajo entonces bueno pues eso lo
implementamos en el código para que en el optimizador no sacara partido de una
situación que fue falsa no pudiste operar ese precio aunque ponga que abrió
entonces cuando hay algo así que no es real que te has podido aprovechar o que
penaliza pues es mejor dejarlo puesto en el código porque así si tú optimizas
no saque partido de una cosa que no fue real es una cosa muy puntual pero bueno
os explico para que lo lo sepáis es ese ese puntos que está implementado y está
como input vale y luego el resto filtr no optimizar esos son variables del de la
gestión monetaria al igual que ésta que es el porcentaje es la f la f de la
gestión monetaria el saldo de la cuenta inicial el lote mínimo el lote máximo
la manera que si le pones uno pues lo bloqueas redondea a uno si quiere
redondear a otro número y hasta todas estas son variables de la de la gestión
monetaria vale que veremos en algún momento veremos en algún momento en
detalle esto voy a comentar en la teoría cuando haremos alguna clase dedicada
sólo a la gestión monetaria entonces qué variables tocamos aquí hay una
variable del indicador de acuerdo hay otras dos variables que no se suelen
tocar esta tampoco esta es una de hecho una prueba que se hizo una vez de un
filtro que está ahí no sé creo que alguna vez lo hemos configurado pero
nuevamente quiere decir que no actúa ese es el valor que os decía de la de la
optimiza y luego vienen los tres podemos decir filtros vale que no no filtros en
el sentido que es un porcentaje multiplicador vale bar 0 1 al final es
una modificador de la orden de entrada y bar 0 2 este p y bar 0 3 es esto no hay
más entonces aquí sólo se analizan en el mapa estas cuatro variables el
indicador y el multiplicador de entrada y el multiplicador del tp multiplicador
del esto esos cuatro es lo que se hace el mapa
para hacer un mapa guardamos todo lo que nos deja tres eso que son 8.000 porque
porque al final en el mapa me interesa ver realmente cuánta más combinación
posible mejor acuerdo en el mapa es importante que haya los menos huecos
posibles vale entre combinaciones por eso idealmente hay que hacer la
exhaustiva vale exhaustiva que pone wfo pero al final no ha sido wfo
entonces bueno esto al final da 49.000 combinaciones que en exhaustiva pues se
hace depende del equipo pero tardaba unas horas con el lift activado y todo
que eran unas horas depende lógicamente de la potencia de la máquina como ya
viste es la teoría o veis en cualquier optimización de tres sesiones y aquí
habrá alguna cargada en alguno de estos aquí no no pues no hay ninguna el que
hecho a no no lo abierto el que del lo que es pero habrá una que está aquí yo
hecho una que la he guardado con ella entonces más que nada para los menos
avanzados en la teoría o que todavía van más atrasados porque si que vemos que
hay ritmos muy muy distintos pues bueno uniforme de optimización donde me lo
has abierto aquí es esto y recordar que siempre hay pues tres hay una que soldada
que reúne los dos periodos el periodo in sample que es el optimizado el
periodo auto sample que es el no optimizado en este caso el último 25
por ciento del histórico en sample auto sample y en los data que lo suma lo
suma a todos vale pues estos datos al final los llevamos a excel más que esto
ya lo visteis en la teoría en todas las hojas simplemente hacemos una
estadística descriptiva abajo del todo también cuando hay 8.000 por dar que
esto sale directamente del propio excel en datos en análisis de datos
estadística descriptiva que saca pues media error típico desviación variancia
cortosis todo esto que veis aquí para todos los parámetros que tú le has
puesto y aquí abajo pues marcamos por ver más rápido mínimo máximo y
mediana es mejor estimador para la mayoría de casos la mediana que la
media la mediana es mejor estimador nuevamente cuando hay outliers cosas
bastante habitual en el trading pero bueno que también si usas la media no
pasa nada si la media si la media la media no son iguales la moda recordar
que eso es en este caso una moda pero si eso será recordar que es una de las
características que tiene una distribución normal que lo visteis o lo
vimos esto en la clase de porfolio en la práctica hay una clase de porfolio
donde se habla del bar el bar todo esto y ahí se ve bastante todo este todo este
tema vale bien esto se recoge hacemos como ya os expliqué por norma siempre los
exes no creo que ya hacemos de manera en los ex y es un excel de búsqueda de
zonas muy inicial en un sistema que no conocemos mucho mejor no lo hacemos pero
normalmente hacemos esto normalizamos las diferencias entre tanto tsi expectancy
como ppc y robustness recordar que robustness compara beneficio medio
analizado con beneficio medio analizado a un sample con in sample y
automáticamente se normaliza con el valor máximo y de ahí sale una suma de
los cuatro de las diferencias respecto a su máximo aquí lo veis a ver aquellos
que entran con este valor si hago si veis que sale la fórmula y es este valor
menos este valor dividido por este valor vale dividido por este valor eso es
normalización típica respecto al máximo lo cual te dice que este valor es
del máximo es un 086 del máximo simplemente para para pues sumarlos todos y de esta manera
buscas un equilibrio entre todos el que tiene un valor de suma más bajo quiere decir que en
estas cuatro referencias pues cumple más equilibrio y todos da buenas notas vale buenas notas este
por ejemplo es en verde pintamos el mejor tsi en naranja pintamos el mejor expectancy score y
en azul pintamos el mejor ppc pero luego repito se ordena o bien por suma o bien por suma sin
rop de acuerdo cuando se usa uno otro cuando optimizamos con el auto sample al final es decir
ahora en la actualidad o lo más cercano a la actualidad entonces usamos suma vale porque
porque el auto sample es cercano y nos interesa al final usar el valor de robunes o no usarlo
para los cálculos de esta de esta de esta suma no es simplemente si yo quiero sobreponderar o darle
importancia a algún dato que compare el in sample color con el auto sample el único dato aquí que
compara eso es el robunes vale robunes compara justamente el rendimiento de un periodo con el
rendimiento del otro por lo tanto si yo quiero darle más peso al auto sample vale usando esta
variable luego de hecho si ordeno por esta variable pues al final estos son los sets que
han ido mejor en el auto sample pero solo eso tampoco lo quiero vale porque también quiero
tener en cuenta las otras variables que tienen en cuenta todo el histórico vale y por eso eso lo
hace la suma porque la suma tiene en cuenta este este este y además este en cambio este último
no tiene en cuenta el suma sin rob no tiene en cuenta el vez provoca otra ordenación distinta
que lógicamente es parecida muchas veces no pero no es exactamente vale bien esto ahora vamos al
mapa luego iremos a los setes aquí no no no no me importa los sets no me importa los sets son
iguales sino porque he elegido 8.000 de acuerdo elegir 8.000 es elegir muchos valios a elegir 8.000
al final yo recordar que esto funciona que optimiza por una función este creo que es el de ese esto
se ha hecho para los tres pero este creo que ha sido aleatorio yo optimizo por esta variable por
expectancia score y escoge los 8.000 mejores en in sample los 8.000 mejores no son muchos y de
ahí de esos 8.000 de esos 8.000 que ha encontrado calcula que anda que que hubieran rendido en el
periodo auto sample lo pone aquí y luego suma los dos aquí el que manda es el in sample el que manda
en el sentido que es el que controla el resto de datos por lo tanto estaremos de acuerdo que
lo una cosa buena es que el in sample se parezca pero eligiendo 8.000 no me da igual igual porque
hay demás elegido he dejado elegir demasiado por lo tanto lo que encuentre como mejor dato aquí
puede ser fruto de una sobre optimización luego veremos que no es tan distinto pero podría ser
a mí para qué me sirve tener 8.000 meses para hacer esto para hacer mapas
a ver un segundo porque tengo por aquí un manejado abierto el whatsapp un momentito que
dejó de compartir un momento la pantalla o sea que ahora tengo que dejar por aquí
cosas abiertas aquí el correo lo voy a cerrar y volvemos a compartir bien mapas en este en esta
estrategia cómo planteamos los mapas yo ya os comenté en la en la teoría que nos gusta
mucho verlos en tablas a nosotros tablas dinámicas no es necesario hacer el típico mapa gráfico y
visual por ejemplo multichars lo hace está bastante chulo está bien es muy aprovechable
de multicharse pero tener eso no lo hace todos lo hacemos en excel y para hacerlo en excel o sea
este mapa a mí no me dice nada más si hago un mapa aquí que esto es tan fácil como seleccionar
la tabla dinámica hacerle así que me lo encuentro aquí superficie y ya está hecho vale a mí esto
me dice más un poco me dice lo mismo que aquí pero lo veo mejor aquí ahora os explico por qué
entonces porque aquí luego lo tengo que mover voy al 3d y como lo muevo así
además del efecto mapa es el efecto escala que siempre se llama de los gráficos pasa igual aquí
vale porque tú dices joder está está muy puntiagudo seguro vamos a hacerlo menos puntiagudo
es verdad está muy puntiagudo ahora porque pasa de opciones aquí vamos a poner aquí si yo creo
que sí que está muy muy puntiagudo mira ya está ya está mejor ya está mucho mejor jate que llanura
más magnífica de parámetros tenemos es una cosa súper estable y súper robusta en que ya está
sistema a operar me entendéis no decir que al final el efecto escala condiciona totalmente el
efecto visual vale para eso tiene tiene multicharts aquello de la del nivel ya os lo la teoría en algún
sistema lo hemos enseñado bueno creo que el otro día en el sistema que hicimos al principio lo
enseñamos también lo enseñamos que ahí enseñamos multicharts por eso aquí pues vamos otra vez más
a excel vamos enseñando un poco de todo no y eso es lo de la marca de agua os acordáis no la marca
de agua a ver si tengo alguno por aquí en la estructura no tenía alguno hecho
no tenía ninguna opción aquí tengo alguno guardado es igual me da igual para no me importa
los datos ahora para que lo veáis es vale cuando tú hacies este gráfico vale le metes esto no
este no es coño es vale y la marca de agua que viene muy bien te viene muy bien porque la puedes
no me acuerdo ahora me acuerdo donde se subió el marcador la marca de agua se vuelve es lo juro
no se movió la marca de a la barra coño es verdad es verdad lo de la memoria míos desde este
película evitas un poco ese efecto con esto ese efecto escala lo puedes tú jugar así porque el
efecto visual cambia totalmente la mente la mente entonces así con esto puedes jugarlo entonces
aquí sí viene muy bien porque es una herramienta que ya se ha pensado para eso tiene esto para
mitigar y viene bien pero en excel a mí prefiero la tabla prefiero la tabla la tabla recordar que
es una tabla dinámica que excel hoy en día y hace de manera automática tú simplemente seleccionas
los valores y le dices aquí insertar tabla dinámica y ya está hecha de verdad esa no no
estoy no estoy exagerando nada pero es que no encontraba bueno te ponen la recomendado
de poner esta la dinámica de seleccionar la tabla bueno aquí me la lleva hasta la derecha del todo
que no me haría falta la quiero más yo la hago más pequeña y ya está voy a hacer para que lo
veáis el rato me cago en el ratón de verdad me cago en el ratón el ratón este me de pronto
me suelta las veces que no tiene pila o qué bueno ya se entiende la idea no bueno pues él
decide hacerlo más abajo para los seleccionas vale los seleccionas ya llegas ahí estamos ahora
venga no pero me falta algo bueno no sé qué he hecho con él pero es igual tú seleccionas
le das a tabla dinámica en una nueva hoja de cálculo y ya está y te genera aquí tú le eliges
cómo montarla con eso que se le profita aquí pero no aquí y el valor y es esto ahora se enseñan
las opciones que nosotros usamos pero es esto para elegir los colores que habéis visto los
colores que habéis visto allí simplemente otra vez seleccionas los colores así y le vienes aquí
formato condicional escala de color no no tiene mucha mucha dificultad
es poquito saber de saber de excel pero ya digo esto el formato condicional luego cuando se ha
metido es aquí no deja de ser un formato para esta columna un formato para esta fila de aquí y un
formato para todo esto y creo que en el que en el nosotros usualmente usualmente utilizamos más
este pero de verdad que he pensado para el curso pensado que os iba mucho mejor mucho mejor utilizaba
este me lo voy a lo voy a poner ahora para que utilizaba más este el de tres colores pero es
verdad que si no lo tienes muy claro te mete un sesgo que hablando loco de alberto nos dimos
cuenta y es verdad esto totalmente es confuso si no lo tienes muy claro porque aquí te da la
sensación que lo peor es el rojo cuando lo peor es el blanco entendés al final lo peor es que no
hayan valores a nivel de mapa es mejor esto que esto entiende no es mejor que haya rojo que haya
blanco entonces al final dijimos hombre pues voló para atrás hay uno que es este es solo blanco
verde y entonces ya claro el blanco es el que tiene poco valor es casi blanco es parecido a este pero
no está entonces este es perfecto este es perfecto entonces pues mira ahora nos pasaremos a nos
pasaremos a este o que nosotros ya lo vemos bien también en el otro porque ya lo ya tenemos muy
interiorizado que el rojo es también bueno pero peor peor que el azul entonces pero pero así
pues bueno se ve muy bien por un único color entonces aquí que hemos hecho de acuerdo hemos
hecho dos mapas es bueno antes veis aquí que lo he hecho por tsi lo he hecho por ppc y lo he hecho
por expectancia score esto realmente no es necesario lo he hecho para demostraros que
no es necesario porque al final el vector clave que hace que el mapa sea bueno o malo es el
hecho de aparecer y lógicamente su valor también tiene importancia pero es al final lo que hace es
acumular todos los valores que dan 4.05 en el resto de variables todas y la relación a uno y te
dice qué valor da la variable de la suma podría podría usar el producto podría usar otros ahora
si yo veáis de dónde viene esto porque ya está montado porque si lo montamos todo no hacemos clase
ya lo vimos en la teoría es aquí una columna estaba bar 0 1 en fila está per 0 1 y los valores que
calcula es suma de ppc vale esto es configurable esto ya digo es pelearse también poco usar la
ayuda de los programas de acuerdo es decir los programas la mayoría tienen buenas ayudas usar
la dinámica y poco a poco mirar vídeos decir hay cosas o sea el curso tratamos que sea completo
pero es imposible que sea profundo en excel profundo en estadística profundo en econometría profundo
es imposible no hacemos mil horas o más no más entonces claro damos las puntas las cosas clave
enseñamos lo que nosotros hacemos es así esto es lo que hacemos nosotros y a partir de ahí claro
mira voy flojo de excel bueno pues vamos a buscar un curso de excel y mejoró mi excel
voy justo de programación bueno pues voy a buscar un curso muy justo tienes tienes que
ir reforzando un poquito aquellas áreas aquellas áreas porque tratamos de explicarlo por encima
lo que no es propiamente la actividad como en este caso excel no lo usamos como herramienta
lo explico un poco pero claro no puedo en profundidad porque si no es que no
le digo estaremos 2000 horas vale entonces aquí dentro de suma yo podría haber elegido otro
elegir el recuento promedio máximo mínimo producto vamos suma y hasta eso es la suma de todos los
valores entonces al final colorcito es muy visual y también los totales generales porque esto cuando
hay la dinámica aquí en el diseño hay una configuración de tabla dinámica nosotros aquí
usamos el esquema que nos gusta usamos totales generales para filas y columnas y subtotales para
ninguno entonces porque ese total al final te está diciendo todos los valores que tiene 0 5 todos
los valores tal todos valores tal pues esto es muy visual vale rápidamente yo veo pero 1 con bar 1
como relaciona pero 1 con bar 1 como relaciona ignorando el resto ahora veremos el resto y aquí
rápidamente pues yo veo que hay dos zonas de peruno buenas está aquí en ambas me toca a lo
que veremos en ambas me toca esto no es deseable quiero decir que aquí me está diciendo que me
he quedado corto debería haber ido al menos a 26 27 porque a mí me interesan mucho en los mapas
los vecinos los vecinos me interesan mucho el mapa no es tanto elegir un ser y al final puedo elegir
un set por mapa pero no es no es elegir un set sino mapa sobre todo me sirve para ver claramente
lo que descarto vale y para ver dónde está las zonas más estables es un análisis de sensibilidad
aquí quiere decir a posero pero este bueno luego veremos si ese me gusta de un perfil más
por adecuado el riesgo pero hombre si si está lo que yo pero lo deseable es que esté dentro
de las buenas zonas del mapa eso es lo deseable lo muy deseable pues el mapa es para ver cómo
estables son los parámetros pues aquí el 4 lo mismo vida debería de ver el 3 para el bien si
luego al final quiero operar con el 4 debería ver el 3 vale porque si en el 3 me pasa como ahora
vais a ver en otro parámetro que me degrada en picado el cuadro no me interesa entendéis como
un poco este caros que este aquí saca la cabeza pero sus vecinos es justo lo veremos lo veremos
tenemos 6 con 10 lo veremos si me lo quedo no me lo quedo bueno podíamos quedarnos poco es
un desastre final recordar que ya estar aquí es bueno es no estar entonces lo que os decía
es tanto con ese y como ppc a ver un momentito que voy a recortar un poco esto para ahora ya
que no tocaré para veros más es que el dibujo es prácticamente el mismo el dibujo es prácticamente
el mismo lógicamente por la magnitud de variables cambian un poco puede tener un pequeño matiz pero
más o menos son iguales le pongo al fines que defines porque lo que lo marca es el hecho de
estar de que salen mucho muchos entre los 8.000 de estos bien aquí relaciono per uno con bar 1
ese es el valor del indicador y esto es el multiplicador del indicador por lo tanto al
final es entrada de acuerdo esta tabla de aquí me está evaluando un poco la entrada y ver qué
combinación de entrada puede ir mejor y aquí tengo stop contra tp salida esto contra de ese
sistema solo sale por esto por la salida contraria que no está contemplada salida contraria es decir
cuando pues aunque sean solo cortos cuando iría largo pues cierra recuerdo cuando iría largo cierra
por esa combinación de parámetros entonces aquí ya veis que lo que os decía parece que 06 de los
60 es muy bueno también es su vecino 06 25 no está mal su vecino 05 65 y tampoco está más
obispo es decir aquí tenemos unos cuatro zonitas bien rodeadas a partir de aquí ya 06 50 hay bueno
ya su vecino no es tan bueno y aquí 565 su vecino ya no es malo del todo peor ya es este vecino es
malos malos vecinos entonces bueno lo ideal lo ideal lo ideal son estos dos son estos dos que
este no se usaste tampoco sea un desastre no es tan malo su vecino es mejor este sí bueno mejor este
pero se nos está malo no está malo vale hasta aquí podríamos llegar podríamos llegar a elegir aquí
pero idealmente aquí y aquí es lo que os digo aquí si elijo 5 bien si elijo 6 bien bueno no
está mal 7 ya y 10 no está mal no está mal que degrada bastante no es ideal y aquí está
muy bien 25 pero me gustaría ver 26 y a los señores porque esa la he hecho me ha dado tiempo
de hacerla pero también haremos la del 3 haremos la de esta zona volvemos a estirar un poco para
ver un poco a ver cómo degrada aquí volveremos a analizarla creo que puede empezar en uno ese
parámetro podemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 hasta 7 que degrada pues hay para ver esta zona ella sola vale bueno
tp y stop tengo algo que contestar que afecte a la clase alberto puedes hablar por el micro
tío que nada no nada sigo pero que vale para después entonces seguimos entonces esto ptp
esto ptp bar 0 2 pp bar 0 3 es esto bueno lo primero que se ve es que el esto pues
esto da igual esto porque es bueno porque es un stop bastante holgado aunque lógicamente
salta más 1 8 que 1 que 2 9 y de hecho reconozco que esperamos un poquito más de gran unidad aquí
esperamos un poco más porque casi no la hay desde casi dice da igual elige el que quieras casi elige
el que quieras además en todos los valores apenas aquí hay algún blanco pero valores muy altos ya
de tp valores muy altos de tp vale y en el tp pues sí que tp bajo algo que nos sorprende
algo que nos sorprende pero pero dentro de no sorprender es muy positivo esta progresión pero
fijaros lo que os digo en el 06 que os decía antes el 05 es drama se me hunde por lo tanto
pero el 06 estoy operando muy justo estoy operando muy justo es decir no es recomendable como mínimo
habría que coger 07 pero podría elegir 07 0 8 0 9 incluso 1 que aquí degrada pero podemos decir
que degrada de una manera más tolerable que aquí no pero bueno a partir de lo ideal ideal sería de
07 a 0 pero yo aceptaría uno en este caso más en un sistema recordar que es un sistema que va
en el nasdaq corto que va en muchos más índices y activos cuando se creó se creó así pero ahora
lo estamos estudiando en el nasdaq y está operando el sistema de hecho ha abierto cortos hoy en algún
set entonces bueno como veis en tp pues más bien rápido a medida que va degradando también degrada
de manera bastante progresiva esto está bien es más o menos progresiva hasta llegar a un punto
donde realmente pero es muy bueno que hayan valores hay valores de acuerdo es decir en todos los casos
hay valores a los que aquí ven muchos no hay valores cuando quien toda la zona de tp stop en
todos prácticamente aparece apenas aquí todos aparecen valores entre los 8.000 tiene está muy
bien distribuido el tp de esto de acuerdo tiene mucho margen tiene bastante tolerancia de acuerdo
son parámetros con tolerancia aquí no la hay tanto sobre todo en este filtro de entrada es un
filtro que tiene una tolerancia justa una de las cosas que hemos revisado en esta optimización
esto me lo he saltado en esta perdón revisión vale donde primero lógicamente se plantean
todo todo al 100% podemos hablarlo por razones obvias pero también por tiempo entonces aquí
hubo un replanteamiento de lo que os dije de este ayúdete input al final eran antes eran dos y nos
dimos cuenta que de hecho era hasta incorrecto el código que eran demasiado rebuscados a dos y
decidimos sacar uno y cambiar el indicador no usar el que es original y crear uno propio para
hacerlo distinto y ahora pues operar con un ser san indicador vale es el indicador que tiene una
pequeña modificación que usa el mismo parámetro para esto y también revisamos analizamos
revisar el los incrementos de estos tres filtros de acuerdo esto recordar que lo detallamos bastante
en la clase de desarrollo teórico hablamos de prudencia con los incrementos con las
optimizaciones porque yo puedo poner aquí 0 0 25 o puedo poner aquí 0 0 0 0 1 y quiero no me
he pasado pero entendéis no entonces al final usar uno u otro no deja de ser un análisis de
sensibilidad que también se hace con mapa este lo lo hicimos previamente ver mapas que varían y
ver los sets pues que hay que variación también se mira mucho aquí en la tabla es decir bueno cómo
varía el mismo set con el siguiente incremento entendéis decir yo busco yo ordeno aquí por
éste y ordenó luego por éste y entonces automáticamente aquí me quedan todos estos
ordenados vale entonces bueno vas jugando hasta que encuentres el mismo no no pero claro que tengo
que desblocarse el otro perdón no estoy haciendo bien vale ahora que tengo este quieto este quieto
y este quieto los imaginaros no bueno es que aquí no hay no hay debate porque el incremento
no puede ser este sería donde hay debate vale entonces yo aquí por ejemplo tengo que buscar
este por ejemplo vez este es igual o grande es una de las maneras de mirar los incrementos esto para
que por si no queda claro que entiendo que sí pero esperaros es así entonces estos dos veis son
iguales es todo es igual 25 2 1 2 9 y sólo cambia el incremento entonces ahí analizar cómo varían
los resultados es importante fijaros que un tick varía 20 trades un cambio bastante importante
esto cómo estaría mal que aquí cambiará o ningún trato un trade y todo fuera casi igual
tenéis eso es un poco hay que buscar un incremento que provoque cierto cambio vale
cierto o cuánto es cierto que no sé no no no lo tengo medido el porcentaje no sé si decir un
10% abierto sería correcto puedes puede estar ahí 10% incremento mínimo vale pero en variación
de significación pero no sé no no no toméis como una cosa sagrada porque es depende de
al final simplemente que varí entonces hay que ver que haya cierta variación a veces te puedes
pasar a veces se puede expresar aquí podríamos pensar que a lo mejor es demasiado y a lo mejor
puedes ganar un poco más pues puede ser a lo mejor podría ver 0 0 25 0 0 2 a lo mejor podía
hacerlo y entonces haría otro mapa y vería a ver vale para regularlo un poco más en vez de
esas nueve sería 11 tenéis pues vendría aquí y vería el mapa a ver a mejor es eso también que
puede ser vale pero ya digo mejor pecar de este conservador en esto que de excesivo vale porque
importante es que haya cierto cambio en el incremento entonces ésta es un poco la variable en
ésta en estos datos que estamos viendo estoy leyendo los datos como los veo trato de no
tener aunque es complicado pero de verdad que trato no tener sesgo de saber el sistema que
hace todo y al final este dato aquí en el mapa es el que parece más sensible de acuerdo más
sensible que ahora sí tiene su zona de trabajo pero es muy estrecha de acuerdo en cambio aquí
hay otras zonas fijaros en el tp también hay una pero también es es bastante bastante larga y
además caros como larga teniendo zona en todos y aquí fijaros que hay muchos blancos aquí no
tanto tp como esto tiene más margen de mano entonces aquí variable delicada podemos decir
que es bar 0 1 en estado en este mapa bueno se podía es lo que se decía se podría volver a
hacer un análisis sensibilidad como habéis visto ahí pues quizá me pasé nos hemos pasado con 0 0
25 a lo mejor vamos a reducirlo a la mitad el incremento a ver a ver qué tal eso es un
multiplicador venga bien visto esto yo aquí tengo un poco unas zonas de trabajo bien
a nosotros nos gusta montar el mapa completo el mapa completo de todos los inputs es decir que
aquí recoge las 8000 esto como yo tengo cuatro monitores no lo ahora no lo vais a ver pero lo
que hago es abrirlo así un estiro y menos tiro los cuatro monitores aquí lógicamente no puedo
porque estoy compartiendo un monitor vale y lo único que puedo hacer es esto que parece que no
pero es bastante útil es bastante útil igualmente porque al final a mí me interesa no me interesan
tanto los valores y me interesan las zonas entender las cosas pero antes antes vamos a
ver porque sin explicar los ejes es complicado que entendáis de que estamos hablando aquí que
tenemos tenemos por un lado aquí tenemos bar 2 y bar 3 y aquí tenemos bar 1 y per 1 es decir
que tenemos las entradas y tenemos las salidas lógicamente hay uno que es el que condiciona más
porque así yo aquí recojo y poder recogiendo ver los extintos voy agrupando si quiero es hacerlo
de hecho puedo filtrar también puedo filtrar expandir o contraer todos expandir todo el campo
vale puedo puedo puedo filtrar y de hecho una de las cosas que hacemos es esa ahora ahora la haremos
es filtrar filtrar pues aquellas zonas que ya me gusta decir que qué cosas tengo clara pues mira
esta de aquí bueno pues vale pues la filtro la voy a bloquear ahí vale pero antes quería que
miráis el mapa teniendo en cuenta lo que lo que os digo aquí tenéis 0 5 luego 0 5 con el 4 con el
6 con el 22 con los que aparece los que hay huecos es que no aparece 0 5 25 con el 4 con el 6 con el
esos son los que los que aparecen y ya te está diciendo que aparecen pocos a esto creo
de cada elemento no era esto había un sitio no me acuerdo no se podían poner los ceros creo
no me acuerdo no me acuerdo no me acuerdo no me acuerdo pero que sí que había un sitio pero
bueno que es igual no importa no importa porque es mejor así porque así ves cuando hay pocas
de 0 5 que he visto así un poco si os fijáis lo veis veis aquí ves es aquí ves uno aquí ves el
otro aquí ves el otro es entonces ves que hay pocos entendéis y esto es lo que te da te da
tu información a medida que lo va reduciendo parece que no parece la cuesta más de ver no pero
aquí por ejemplo hasta en 20 que ya casi casi la llenamos toda vamos a ver ligeramente no se ve
cuando cuando nos reduzca si en 30 sé que se ve creo es verdad que ya le hemos le hemos quitado
el micro hemos quitado un poco es aquí aquí sí que se ve es aquí tienes uno aquí tienes otro
aquí tienes otro vale entonces claro estos ya se ve que tienen muy pocos en cambio aquí fijaros
tiene muchos muchos está que llega al final que también casi no tiene en el filtro en el filtro
de entrada por entendernos vale el filtro de entrada aquí pasa lo mismo con el tema de
tp y stop y primero este p que fijaros aquí en general son muy parecidos porque aparecen todos
lo habéis visto antes excepto este último que aparecen algunos menos nada bajo el todo pero en
este no no no aparecen los aquí insisto no importa tanto leer los valores no se ve nada
vale vale es igual no importa aquí ahora ya tú porque ya te lo he dicho sabes dónde está cada
cosa a ver un segundo una más 20 ahí 15 15 15 15 15 se ve se ve ahí se ve ahí enterita entonces
ya digo no importa tanto no importa tanto el hecho de ver los valores sino de entender un
poco el dibujo aquí claramente es donde está el 06 de arriba y donde es más ancha y porque el 06
ahora veréis veíais arriba de acuerdo aquí en la pequeñita quedaba más porque veis el 06 tiene
aquí donde donde tiene zona de tp baja vale que es donde está esta es la zona de tp baja espera que
voy a pintar esto evidentemente es la zona de tp bajo es evidente vale pero fijaros que el 06
incluso en zonas de tp altas tiene valores en cambio su vecino en 5 7 5 no tanto 5 5 tampoco
vale y para arriba mejor ahora llegando a lo que dices pues oye cuidado es verdad que en la
zona mismo tampoco tiene tanto pero es progresiva el 1 en sí es bastante progresivo también entonces
esto es lo que nos permite ver el mapa un poco global que se ve mejor en 4 en 4 monitores pero
visto esto quería simplemente que lo vierais ahora vamos a filtrarlo para que lo veáis mejor para
que lo veáis mejor y vamos a limitar al limitar a bloquear los inputs que son más claros bar 0 2
por un lado vale par 0 2 por un lado que es recordar el tp y bar 0 1 que es el filtro de entrada
por entenderlo se hace aquí entonces donde los bloqueo aquí bueno yo puedo venir aquí la variable
y le digo bueno pues de ver 0 1 lo voy a ver sólo desde 0 55 a 0 65 sólo voy a bloquear esos
porque bueno porque el 0 55 ya no es bueno pero me interesa ver por vecino de acuerdo me interesa
ver siempre el vecino aquí incluso podía haber puesto este vamos a poner 0 55 0 6 7 5 por ver
también el vecino vale 0 6 7 5 yo ahí añado el vecino vale y lo mismo voy a hacer para la del
tp que el 0 5 es virria pero quiero verlo quiero verlo porque quiero ver este caso no me haría ni
falta porque es muy claro que es virria pero yo lo quiero ver quiero ver vale pero 5 hasta 1 1
porque quiero ver el vecino del 1 quiero ver el vecino del 1 vale que lo veíamos ahí será
este es este 1 1 quiero ver ahora ya lo he bloqueado vamos a usar tamaños vale y ahora
evidentemente sólo con esos dos ya vais a ver que va a ser más sencillo analizarla vale ser un poco
más sencillo sigue habiendo mucho pero con el trenta ya casi llegaba si el trenta casi casi está
ahí queda un poco entonces aquí ya se ve un poco mejor recordar que a la izquierda tengo así en
filas tengo tp y su stop y arriba tengo entrada entonces este es el esta fila que vemos aquí tan
tan flojita vale esta fila es el 0 5 de tp de acuerdo con sus stops 0 5 en cada distinta
rango de entrada vale lógicamente aquí donde tiene 0 6 donde tiene 0 6 veis pues es donde
tiene tiene mejor de acuerdo tiene mejor dato hay el 0 5 es esto es lo bueno lo que habla de
la robustez de una variable es esto es que no es sólo donde le va bien sino también en otras
zonas de muestra esto indica que es zona robusta de ese parámetro tendéis pero es verdad que como
veis como decía partir de la que sacas el 0 5 del tp también casi que ha sido igual no 0 6 7 todas
todas están muy bien todas están muy bien todas están muy bien no está este es 0 6 de tp este es
0 7 de tp 0 8 0 9 1 y 1 1 y en toda la zona incluso que al principio de todo que es la zona
primera del 0 5 5 no debía ser 0 5 5 creo que puesto de de bar 0 1 del filtro filtro el bar 0 1
vale este es 0 5 5 estos 5 7 5 6 6 25 entonces bueno pues incluso aquí se ve bastante bastante
de todo me parece que me falta una estaba estaba contando mientras lo decía me faltaba
efectivamente una esta es 5 5 esta esta de aquí 5 5 5 y estas 5 7 5 y estas 6 bueno entonces lo
que os decía aquí en la variable 5 5 hay pocas pero fijaros que en toda la columna en todos los
niveles de tp y estopa y esto es por el que el motivo el tp de estopa es poco sensible porque
en todas las zonas de póngase el póngase el filtro salen te pesa esto lógicamente en los
que salen más que en otros pero en todos hay zonas un parámetro bastante da margen de maniobra
su sensibilidad es buena tiene buena tolerancia vale a medida que aumenta pues ya van apareciendo
apareciendo pocos entonces de esta manera yo puedo ver el mapa mejor aquí por ejemplo
eliminando los los mapas si os fijáis a ver si consigo que lo veáis es interesante que veáis
una cosa que hemos visto en el mapa aquí quería quería verlos aquí fijaros que en el 5 7 5 que
aquí ves 4 5 7 5 de filtro con el indicador en 4 5 6 7 que ahí hemos visto que era buena
zona no picaros que en esta zona me lo voy a marcar mejor con un cuadradito a los que en esta
zona con 4 5 6 vale tiene hasta mejores valores en 0 6 lo veis que tiene 4000 es aquí 3000 por el
color ya se ve no es decir en esta zona es mejor es mejor 5 7 5 es bueno tiene valores realmente
elevados porque 6 cuando lo agrupas aquí arriba sale mejor porque cuando lo ves aquí resumido
vale cuando aquí pinta sólo pero 1 contra bar 0 1 ignorando el resto es decir todas están recogidas
aquí vale aquí sí que veis claro que 6 es mejor que 5 7 5 bueno la respuesta es muy muy sencilla
la habéis visto antes incluso en la en la zona donde estaban todos que el 0 6 distribuye mucho
en todos no sólo en los buenos en los buenos en las en su zona óptima 5 7 5 parece hasta mejor
pero 6 es un todo terreno espectacular en todas las zonas mete bastantes valores en todas en todas
incluso las que no están aquí ahora las hemos quitado recordar que lo hemos visto antes lo voy
a volver a poner el mapa completo para que lo veáis lo que quiero decir eso es porque 6 en la
zona óptica no es el mejor mejores 5 7 5 pero aquí lo veis es pero hasta hasta cuando no es bueno
mete mete más y también aquí aunque no lo parezca es en esta zona aquí tiene más aquí que aquí y
realmente 0 6 es el que tiene mejor tolerancia mejor tolerancia es un valor bueno pero cuidado
que es muy muy importante en un mapa vamos por zonas no se trata de decir si luego metemos un
set que está ahí pues de coña pero son las zonas de acuerdo de entender dónde dónde me muevo yo
mejor donde mis sets pueden estar más justos vale bien esto se va siguiendo la vuelta por ahí o que
o asatiendo ahora de si pregunta jaime si hablando de los incrementos en los inputs hay alguna forma
de elegir en cuanto poner los incrementos sería probando que explica ser sí no no esto te lo
decía jaime no no hay vaya nosotros no no no no tenemos ningún método vale que puede ser que
lo haya nosotros explicamos lo que lo que hacemos al final lo normal es que un porcentaje sea
razonable cuando es incrementar lo permita porque si usas un indicador imagínate que eso sea una
media móvil pues número entero no pero si tú estás metiendo aquí un porcentaje como es el
caso es un multiplicador un multiplicador es un porcentaje de acuerdo entonces al final
como los regulas a 0 0 1 a 0 1 a 0 0 0 1 tienes hay que buscar sentido común aquí
la verdad que como os he dicho que voy a hacer otra seguramente haremos una prueba porque me ha
parecido que la variación es bastante notable a mí esta variación ha parecido bastante notable
hay que ver que realmente dependen los otros inputs hay que mirarlo en distintas zonas ahora
habría que buscar uno en el 4 tienes en el 4 4 o algo así que actúe muy distinto o con el
filtro más cercano no sé distintas combinaciones no con tepes cercanos pero es verdad que este
nivel es elevado para ser el incremento 20 trades sobre sobre 600 y pico son bastantes
pudiera ser que aceptara un poco más de granularidad entonces
casi con total seguridad lo tenemos que hablar luego con con alberto porque pero es posible
que podamos evaluar reducirle un poco más porque como digo 23 son bastantes y es verdad que es
el incremento que se ve que va un poco justo con lo cual puede ser que sea justo porque
lo dejamos que arruinar pocos al final esto esto siempre va todo esto siempre va de señal y de
ruido de acuerdo entonces no hay que pasarse con o sea igual que no hay que pasarse con la
sobre optimización es decir en el sentido de que le permites ajustarse tanto tienes que dejarles
suficientes grados de libertad para que se ajuste me entienden para que se ajuste a la señal no
quiero decir algo para que para que pueda captar la señal si yo no le permito un mínimo vale
imagínate que yo este filtro le pongo de de 5 en 5 es imposible no puedo no soy capaz de contar
nada ahí porque me estás me estás obligando a trabajar en parámetros de locura o como si yo
digo por si el mercado que hay un 5% de pones largo bueno cuántas veces que a un 5% tiene
al final todo tiene su nivel no como todo en la vida al final tanto es malo como poco siempre
mejor pecar de prudencia y protegerse contra la sobre optimización mucho pero aquí en un
sistema que tenemos que conocemos más que a mi hija casi vale que lleva dos días alberto si
será capaz de decir menos años que lleva polo pero pero apolo puede llevar 15 años en el mercado
alberto es el 14 como mínimo está no pues igual llamas con algunas pequeñas modificaciones
que es que ha demostrado operar todo tipo de mercados
mercado muy un sistema muy muy robusto vale que lógicamente de fin cuando pues hay que ajustarlo
pero es muy robusto entonces bueno se puede se puede apretar un poco más las tuercas pero
pero siempre prudencia pero es verdad que ya digo 23 sobre 600 y pico insisto que es el menor
incremento posible parece demasiado así visto así en eso parece demasiado pero claro esto que
mirarlo en más tres de más zonas y concluir a lo mejor esto ha sido una casualidad y resulta que
normalmente se mueve tres tríceps pero bueno si fuera a cinco tríceps estaría mejor estos 20
tríceps para ser el menor incremento puede ser demasiado así que lo lo miraremos lo miramos
y nos pareció que era el adecuado pero así es la vida del público se ve siempre mirando cosas
vale la del fran la de arriba la dejo para el final de manuel o vale ok
a ver que traduzco porque utilizamos el tsi es ppc los mamas en vez de utilizar el roc no sería
mejor al tener diversas versiones de fitness funciona agrupadas no acabo de entender es que
al final tú necesitas la suma tú quieres decir el valor que recoge la tabla no le veo no le veo
pero puedes puedes ponerlo pero no le veo mucha no le veo mucha mucho sentido fran pensándolo ahora
pero porque al final el robot es el robot es un valor que es importante pero aquí cuando estás
con 8.000 tiene un sesgo se tiene unas una posible sobreutilización gigantesca y de hecho vas
a ver roburnes con valores absolutamente locos que no sé qué he hecho antes que me lo me he
cargado la tabla no venga perfecto vamos pues lo vuelvo a abrir no sí porque lo de abajo lo de abajo
lo puedo volver a lo puedo volver a mover en un momento no no guardo venga tira no sé qué he hecho
antes seleccionándolo todo con el ratón que se me ha ido a tomar y ahora no quería lo todo para
atrás o sea al final el robot es en sí compara insample con el sample es un valor importante es
un valor importante pero en este punto al haber 8.000 de acuerdo vas a ver que hay valores o sea
su dispersión es brutal la dispersión es brutal bueno vemos abajo la dispersión no para eso está
de 296 a menos 74 la suma de los roburnes a la columna suma perdona perdona pues sí sí o sea no
cambiaría nada fran no cambiaría si si puedes usarlo no tiene ningún problema no creo de
verdad me he probado a cambiar algo y hemos descubierto aquí algo puede ser perfectamente
pero no creo que cambie porque al final a cambiar a los valores lógicamente pero quiero decir que el
hecho de cuál es mejor o peor no creo que cambie porque es muy parecido a uno de otro de acuerdo al
final tú tienes a ver aquí que no he hecho la tabla tan grande no lo he incluido no lo he
incluido déjame momento tengo que hacer con la última porque no tiene espacio para expandirse
y a ver en esta si me deja ahora le cambiaron no le cambiaron esta venga muy bien se llevamos
una casualidad y que me hablas con el exhaustivo pasa veces abierto sí pero antes hace hace mucho
rato te he dicho que acabaría a ocho y media si te acuerdas cabra ocho y media cabra ocho y media
parecido ahora claro son valores negativos porque ese valor era negativo por lo tanto
tenemos que crear el color al revés pero eso no tiene mayor importancia porque ya lo tiene previsto
el mismo programa es y puede haber alguna pequeña diferencia no sabe no está mal es decir lo veo
bien de hecho mira lo probaré una unas cuantas veces nosotros normalmente ponemos en el profit
yo los he puesto ahí otros he puesto ese y pero normalmente hacemos net profit no no tiene no es
un gran vector vale esto en sí bueno aquí no y mejor este sí que tiene como poner a un poquito
más abajo que arriba si te fijas pero es bastante parece pero porque lo he puesto ahora porque es
negativo donde aparece más es es bastante similar es bastante similar y bueno como veis ya digo no
si lo haces por net profit que lo solemos hacer por net profit voy a poner este por net profit me
deja bueno de la derecha mismo porque si no a veces no te deja no te deja añadir es como lo
solemos hacer pero es que es también muy muy parecido cambia muy poco normalmente lo hacemos
por el prójito lo he puesto aquí un poco para que lo para que lo vierais para que vierais las
funciones que vamos usando pero es esto muy similar porque al final lo que marca sobre todo
en esto es el hecho de aparecer claro que puede haber un pequeño matiz del dato pero pero es
pequeño es pequeño es muy parecido es bastante parecido como ya como ya esperaba pero no es
incorrecto o sea como concepto me gusta no pasa que ya al trabajar al ser un número negativo ya
pues ya tienes que interpretar al revés a lo mejor y sabes es por simplicidad ya digo el net
profit suele ir bien para para hacer un mapa por donde el mapa que sea lo más extenso posible que
cubra todas las mayores zonas posibles y que los incrementos estén bien lo que hablamos ahora bien
seguimos aquí abajo en el mapa dejarme repasar las notas de lo que he ido diciendo hasta ahora
porque este es uno de los días que tengo más guión porque no quería dejarme nada quería dejarme
nada vale vale es así ya hemos filtrado el mapa grande ahora lo voy a volver a poner a hacer vamos
a volver a hacer lo del mapa grande que si os lo digo esto parece que no que puede resultar poco
útil verlo así pero pero ya arriba se ve bien pero a nosotros nos gusta nos gusta partir del
grande luego ir filtrando no filtrando lo y hasta que ahora lo vamos a volver a hacer porque como
he tenido que abrirlo porque no sé que había liado pues lo volvemos a lo volvemos a ver ponemos
aquí desde este desde el tp hemos dicho que vamos desde el 0 5 al 1 1 vale el bar 1 hemos dicho que
lo llevábamos desde el lo que 55 65 al final de 21 más 55 y dijimos aquí meter el 0 6 7 5
también se no tenía que apuntar lo voy a apuntar pero 6 7 5 y luego también podríamos tocar los
otros no tiene mucho sentido tocar el esto porque es lineal pero sí que aquí podemos dejar estas
zonas por ejemplo de 4 a 7 no es un poco el vecino dejar solo el 4 al 7 7 por un lado y luego
el otro lado pues el 22 al 25 22 a 25 ahí tiene el problema que hemos tocado límite también arriba
24 25 más 22 y bueno así pues el mapa de abajo es un poquito más
manejable ya pues se queda todo como veis bastante bastante agrupado porque nos hemos
cargado los buenos hemos dejado los límites de acuerdo y vemos un poco la misma información
que teníamos queda más limpio queda más más limpio el mapa pero nada nada más bien aquí
podemos marcar un poco nuestro set ideal vale nuestro set ideal que aquí tenemos una duda
que mira os la voy a enseñar ya porque la he hecho esta he hecho he hecho esta zona 2 porque
quería ver ese 25 quería ver la he hecho hecho esto lo he hecho último ahora por su trabajo
estaba acabando vale y que de hecho mira ves aquí sí que hemos apuntado los los datos sample que
eso me gusta el otro se nos ha olvidado pero en este veo que sí que lo ha puesto con muy buen
muy buen criterio porque nos gusta ponerlo pero se nos había nos había olvidado vale y esto nos
gusta ponerlo y antes de empezar igual que se mira los incrementos se analiza esto se analiza
esto donde están los cortes donde se analiza pues lo que habéis visto antes vale espera me lo voy
a poner aquí para yo verlo gráfico idealmente si uno no le tiene una gran sensibilidad al sistema
no lo conoce tanto pues se puede hacer en distintos cortes y te puede hacer delante y detrás que ya
sabéis que nos gusta mucho pero aquí poquito como os digo es un sistema amplio rango de
comportamiento bastante de por humano entonces pues bueno no lo complicamos tanto en ese sentido
pero al final si yo veo aquí todo aquí lo voy a ver poco pero bueno poco este mira lo voy a
quitar el sistema momento 17 29 de diciembre del 17 por aquí más o menos por aquí más o menos
es el corte no aquí era más o menos por ahí más o menos por ahí es el auto sample es decir de
ahí para adelante es auto sample aquí lo ideal para aquellos que no han hecho deberías de tener
a un indicador de volatilidad y tendencia o puede ser también la de x pues tener tanto la de x con
el histórico si lo tenéis o cualquier otro indicador ahora ocultar es un momento y ahí pues
veis un poquito las dinámicas que lleva el mercado aquí pues ha tenido ciclos bajistas
ha tenido crack del kovit en ese ciclo bajista y de hecho hay bastante ciclo bajista recuerdo
bastante ciclo bajista y aquí en el histórico pues hay también un poco de todo porque hay
una gran crisis primera del 2000 muy larga vale luego un período lateral bastante duro bastante
duro otra nueva caída y luego un ciclo bajista espectacular por eso que hay un poquito de todo
se pueden hacer distintas estudios de aquí dejar auto sample la parte inicial en los cortos
normalmente hace un auto sample bestialmente bueno vale bestialmente bueno aquí no no es fácil
porque es verdad que ahora en proporción hay bastante corto vale y no tendría no estaría
tampoco mal alargarlo un poco más y es a lo mejor a 30 por ciento el problema del
porcentaje es que si tú le dejas muy poco en sample hay autores incluso pardo que comenta
alguna vez y nosotros alguna vez lo hemos hecho es como prueba de 50 a 50 es 50 a 50 y si es un
sistema con muchísimos trades es bien de acuerdo es válido vale pero aquí hablamos de un diario es
un sistema que tiene muchos trades pero que operan diario pero que te operan diario y esta
optimización tiene muchos trades la están hablando de la mayoría de 700 800 500 depende
no hasta mil en algún set pero a son muchos pero tampoco son tantos por dos decir realmente
yo en el in sample metido así pues estoy metiendo 500 600 claro si lo pongo menos
sample le meto menos entonces capto menos señal este es el equilibrio de señales
entonces es complicado en esos sistemas y en este tipo por ejemplo el 50 a 50 pero en uno podría
ser y este por mercado estaría chulo de acuerdo porque es verdad que ahora tiene un poquito de
sesgo bajista en este en el auto aunque ha subido mucho porque es como bajista poder desde aquí
aquí ha subido un montón sí pero ha tenido bastantes tramos de caída y hay en el en el
in sample también en el sample también pero es verdad que tiene un tramo de montonazo de años
veis o a súper alcistas y luego a cambio tiene dos tramos súper bajistas para un mercado de
bolsa súper bajistas este es súper bajista y este es súper bajista entonces realmente todos
súper bajistas uno muy muy largo luego aquí un poco de todo pero un poco de todo pero veis
aquí tiene momentos de elevada volatilidad de muy baja volatilidad tiene un poquito de todo y lo
mismo en el ADX lo mismo lo ves en el in sample que veréis periodos de muchísima volatilidad y
periodos de muy poca volatilidad pero en porcentaje en el in sample tiene un poquito más de periodo
de poca volatilidad que ahora es un poquito el único sesgo que tiene la muestra pero es
complicada quitársela aquí es complicada como vamos aumentando el histórico seguramente ya para
las siguientes ya lo podemos anotar en nuestras notas alberto que le llevaremos cinco más porque
ya vas ganando histórico por lo tanto cada vez tienes más trade siempre no y meterle ir a ir
abriendo a llevarlo un poco más atrás el 30 para ganar periodos sin volatilidad de acuerdo en el
auto sample pero claro yo necesito suficientes trade en el in sample también pero ese es un
poco el problema que plantea los sistemas de este tipo bien volviendo al mapa aquí ya lo
tenemos filtrado y lo que os decía yo aquí puedo tener un poquito mi set ideal mi set ideal que
está claro que está en la zona de 06 del bar 1 y que en la zona del en la zona del indicador
bueno la zona de indicador no es tan claro no es tan claro pero bueno pues ahí tenemos 6 tenemos
5 4 y 25 es muy bueno el problema es que no tengo vecinos por eso os decía que había hecho el otro
donde estaba aquí esto es simplemente la misma que hemos hecho pero en b como 425 esto lo has
cambiado tu algo alberto has copiado aquí algo y no habrás copiado los inputs no no no es esa no
se ha hecho esa opti seguro el mapa es short zona 2 eso no se está seguro pues pues no sé me habré
equivocado a recogerla pero estará de 23 a 30 es de 23 a 30 es estará de 23 a 30 es esta la
que se ha hecho aquí se ha hecho está seguro 23 a 30 esto es la que se ha hecho dejando todos
los demás igual pero dejando sólo el valor del indicador de 23 centa para qué para ver ese más
allá del 25 a ver qué pasaba está todo igual recogido todo igual vale con sus marcas sus
estadísticas y demás vale no vamos a pararnos mucho aquí vamos a ir un poco a los mapas vale
esos son los mapas como veis de 23 a 29 porque el 30 pues igual no sale porque no debe salir el
30 en ningún 30 si que hay 30 así porque no sale de 30 a ver si no saben los datos sí pero
si hay datos sale está recogido está recogido bien vale vale bueno no sé por qué
no sé por qué porque no está filtrado vamos a poner el net profit para no no me va a dejar ahora
claro gracias y las siete si está desorderado esta habrá que poner el sonido deja invitada
no sé por qué no es arderado
lo sé porque lo sabrá porque por defecto es arderado pero no sé por qué no lo estaba y por eso
no me daba no me daba cuenta gracias gracias al que lo ha puesto lo he hecho para ver si
estabais atentos de realidad esto lo hago mucho yo lo he hecho para ver si estabais atentos así
que muy bien que lo haya hecho tiene un punto positivo para examen final final de curso
queremos esta la escalita de color bien fijaros que lo primero que vemos es que el 06 sigue
sigue dominando en toda la zona da igual el valor que le des al indicador que él sigue siendo el
rey vale y y que vemos que el 25 efectivamente destaca y sí que vemos que degrada degrada
bueno degrada no no creo que degrada de manera para no usarlo no creo que degrada para la manera
de no usarlo pero sí que hay una cierta ahí degradación no no menor vale no menor a ver si
aquí en el mapa de abajo del todo grande vemos alguna cosa adicional quiero ser más estrecha
así que me va a venir bien ocultar esto y podíamos para cinco minutitos igual no así que si vamos
a parar cinco minutitos si os parece y así reposamos un poco un poco todos a ver que pongo el
contador un momento de pánico porque no veía el marcador de la grabación digo matame matame que
no duela por favor venga pues vamos con vamos con una pausita de cinco minutitos y vuelvo casi
estiró un poquito las piernas y voy a visitar a un amigo que tengo ahí hasta ahora pues ya estamos
por aquí y seguimos con la clase yendo yendo yendo al baño se me ocurrió una cosa en relación
con lo que decías de los incrementos es que es que veis para que veas una una cosa que puedes
mirar por eso la pregunta que queda ahora que hemos para una buena idea mira preguntaba antes
Juan Manuel en futuras prácticas será alguna óptica como esta con el mapa con tabla dinámica
ya que la teoría se hace una vez por encima y rápido y sería clave para dominarlo verlo hacer
desde cero completo al menos una vez o sea como el pensar que los vídeos los puedes ver 70 veces
si quieres o sea yo creo que que todo el proceso lo he mostrado si tienes alguna hora concreta
pasamos la etapa tenemos de resolverla pero es que una tabla dinámica o sea tú seleccionas los
valores y le das al botón es que no tiene más de verdad y no lo hago con el rato con el texto
porque se me va no sé antes lo intentado y se me ha ido a tomar viento no es cual imagínate que
se acabará aquí insertar tabla dinámica y te abre y luego tú aquí eliges un valor en columna y
un valor en filas lo que quiera representar y quiere representar uno contra otro y el cual
pones en uno y otro es prueba error o sea no hay un que tú quieras ver más antes y aquí el valor
que recoge net profit ya está es que no es más una tabla dinámica y lo que te digo buscas tablas
dinámicas en youtube están 250 vídeos pero que no hay más bueno luego claro configurarla pero
como cualquier otra cosa pues ya incluso hay con cosas de gusto que te decía nosotros para que
quede grabado nosotros no mostramos subtotales sí que mostramos activado para filas y columnas
totales generales pero a lo mejor habrá gente que no le gusta y tal los sumas entonces sólo
ves los inputs sin las sumas y el diseño me gusta el esquema porque me enseña y las variables y no
lo otro que no lo enseña pero eso es totalmente gusto no tiene nada y ya está todo esto cuando
quieres marcar un color haces así y es una opción de éxodo que se llama formato condicional vale que
depende de los datos pues pinta de un color o le pone barritas o le pone iconitos ves estos son
opciones del excel cuál va mejor para esto pues a nosotros gusta esto pero mira antes usamos esto
y a partir de esta semana hemos cambiado a este y aquí usamos este formato condicional barras de
datos cual da igual si es un color o otro no tiene mayor es esto una una una más de verdad es que
más que esto o sea tú dices explicamos poco a poco que no te lo puedo explicar de otra manera
es esto es esto y ha quedado grabado ha sido muy rápido pues vuelvelo a ver vuelvelo a ver
vuelvelo a ver te pones la pausa lo pruebas tú lo ves a ver la gracia de los vídeos es esa tienes
que tú puedes parar el vídeo hacerlo entiendes al final es un poco el tema vale pues ya está como
se marca ha respondido esto pero como se hace ha respondido ha entendido gracias pero la banderita
no me la deja quitar a si nada pregunta a mí vale está vale estaba y bueno no sé cómo quitar la
banderita vale bien entonces lo que nos decía en el mapa del 2 de la zona esta que también lo
tenemos total pues bueno se viene a apreciar más o menos lo mismo no hay ninguna novedad lo único
queríamos ver es cómo evolucionaba más allá del 25 y bueno pues no hay una gran ecatombe sí
que hay cierta degradación se parece claro que el 25 es una zona muy muy top pero bueno aguanta
bien tiene bastantes valores y sería mejor que degradar menos sí pero no es tampoco muy dramático
si lo vemos aquí abajo a ver siempre bueno aquí nos va a costar de ver vamos a bloquear vamos a
hacer una cosa como queremos ver este parámetro lo que vamos a hacer ahora es lo que os decía
a veces de los de los datos sea el hecho de que uno vaya antes o después lo marca simplemente
el orden en que tienen aquí ahora voy a poner el p1 arriba porque pues nada pues porque así el
que manda primero es el perro entonces ya la dejo solo pero como que cuatro está mal pero si no
hay cuatro aquí no o que cuatro esto no ha actualizado esta tabla ya verás se ha dado un
actualizado no entiendo porque sale cuatro si no hay datos de cuatro y no y nuevamente no está
ordenado de menos a más y en el bar 2 pues le dejo ya los ya conocidos no vale voy a dejar
solo los tres los tres megatops y fijaros que nos queda una tabla ya muy muy reducida nos queda
es muy larga con lo cual le voy a cortar también a los que aquí el 06 es más estable que fijaros
que en la zona elevada esto es bastante interesante fijaros que el tp y el stop como que degrada
menos lo veis por eso el 25 en la otra salía tan bueno es porque en la zona de tp a partir
del 1 también va degradando pero es como degrada de manera bastante más progresiva que antes cuando
estaba la zona del 4 al 25 pues ya les cuenta no decir en esta zona de 25 estas son las cosas
que conclusiones que sacamos en el mapa que la acabo de sacar ahora la zona sigue siendo igual
en la zona de tp bajo bar 02 también le agrada mucho en el 05 que quizá un poco menos pero le
agrada mucho tiene el 6 el 7 el 8 9 el 1 y hasta el 1 muy bien y ahí en el 1 1 empieza a degradar
pero fijaros que empieza de manera de manera mucho más progresiva que antes aquí el 1 es mejor en
la zona de 25 en la zona alta más de 23 en este segundo grango que veíamos en la otra no en la
otra habíamos ya visto ese ese rango aquí lo que pasa que acababa en 25 vale queríamos ver más allá
acababa en 25 pero ya veíamos que ahí había aquí había algo bueno es como ya salía claro 18 25
era era la leche ahora hemos ido más allá para ver qué pasa tras esto no y nos hemos dado cuenta
que a la que vimos de 23 a 25 no automáticamente vez esa degradación que es mucho menor aquí es
mucho menor en el otro caso y ya más adelante fijaros aquí en la zona de tp es incluso el 1
6 aquí ya prácticamente no no sale casi y aquí en cambio fijaros no lo séis pero está todavía
todavía tiene bastante bastante buen dato decir realmente degrada de manera mucho más progresiva
en la zona del indicador a más de 23 vale es decir elegir 24 25 está bastante bien aquí es una
zona muy buena es decir teníamos aquella zona que veíamos 5 6 pero también está también está cual
bueno parece 26 mejor pero fijaros 25 también 25 muy bien 25 muy bien y su vecino 24 24 es bastante
bueno también hay su vecino perdón decía 25 digo su vecino 23 24 25 25 están bien también aquí
a ver que le he cortado demasiado que no que he pasado que ver que no le he puesto 24 23 pongo
23 pongo todo y está para verlo para verlo bien 23 24 25 26 27 y si fijaros que incluso 23 aparece
aquí 0 6 0 6 25 24 muy bien una columna realmente extensa todo todo todo todo muy progresiva va
degradando va degradando lógicamente va degradando pero fijaros que degrada de manera realmente
aquí otra vez otra cosa que voy a cambiar aquí que esto lo ves en los mapas al ir haciéndolo no
tiene mayor mayor historia es decir me va a llevar un pequeño bajito no muy largo pero un pequeño
de cambiar de una separado uno lo voy a llevar aquí porque la prefiero más alargada no porque
la pantalla es más alargada me va mejor así me da mejor así dejo pero uno arriba vale y dejo
bardos arriba para que me mande el tp justo ahora el problema es que seguramente esto no está bien
ya se ha hecho un lío importante lo vamos a volver a hacer porque esta vez es cuando cambien
los datos pasa es un poco lío pero así es le montamos esta bueno espérate que la vamos a
faltar un poco por mucho que es mejor no no tanto no tanto entonces el filtro aunque ya
vemos que va realmente bien lo vamos a dejar solo del 0 6 0 5 no lo dejamos dejamos lo 0 5
vale pero le vamos a dar hasta el 1 1 igualmente no es que la verdad aquí por dejarle le puedes
dejar hasta donde quieras porque realmente va muy muy bien y el esto pues queda igual lo
mismo no esto pasa un poco igual esto no sabes ni dónde cortarlo el esto es que lo sabes ni
dónde cortarlo no sabes de dónde cortarlo aquí tenemos esta hora y siendo larguísima la verdad
así pues bueno sigue costando mucho porque es enorme la zona es enorme que se vería mucho
mejor pero no se ve mucho mejor a lo subo un poco mejor a lo subo poco mejor voy a quitar el 0 5
porque algo ganaremos voy a quitar uno en cada lado algo bajamos no algo es algo bueno es es
realmente homogéneo realmente homogéneo como como veíamos y está muy bien bueno tenemos tenemos
más o menos más o menos claro más o menos claro que el indicador no está no lo hemos hecho pero
estaría bien también esto mismo que hemos hecho para arriba también hacerlo es decir hacer de 1
a 7 por ejemplo de 1 a 7 todo igual tendés decir hacer esto de 1 a 7 esta misma que la vamos a dejar
ahora puesta alberto en ordenador de 1 a 7 para mañana analizarla y así veremos un poco qué pasa
en ese 4 qué pasa en ese 4 para ya no es lo mismo que hemos visto aquí pero bueno en principio
vemos que está 456 sobre todo 56 de acuerdo 456 está está bastante bien no 456 pues parece
parece ser buena buena zona no 456 porque incluso 7 pues es una degradación bastante aceptable
aceptable por el lado de aquí ya hemos visto que entre 575 porque aún aún dejaría aún este
vecino lo consideramos aceptable y aquí 0650 pero bastante por los pelos bastante por los pelos
idealmente 0625 pero bueno 0650 aún podría aún podría valer en cuanto al lado del en cuanto al
lado del tp 06 este sí que lo vamos a descartar por el enorme barranco que supone 05 vale y
aceptaríamos hasta uno hasta uno pero es verdad que mirando la otra ahí vemos un poquito más de
tolerancia de acuerdo aquí vemos que en la zona elevada esa zona de 456 antes no le mencionaba
que la quería mencionar aquí pero también está de acuerdo también tenemos 24 25 no pero ya está
como la iba a ver aquí pues ya no la he tratado y no pero tenemos esta tenemos esta zona que
nos está nos está diciendo que 24 incluso 23 no cosa 23 porque el 22 una degradación aún aceptable
aún aceptable yo de 23 24 25 23 es decir tenemos 456 y 23 24 y 25 esto además tiene un plus que
de hecho es lo queríamos haber dejado preparado pero pero no sabemos porque eso nos boqueaba la
optimización y no hemos podido porque porque eso ya os lo digo este sistema lleva mucho tiempo
operando esta zona de 23 24 y 25 es una zona top del lado largo de acuerdo el lado largo opera
varios sets no sólo operan sino que han operado durante años en esa zona de acuerdo es una zona
muy fina para el lado largo entonces eso también está y de hecho hay algún set también el corto
operando en esa zona hoy en día es decir que sé que esto no es nuevo esto como os digo viene de
siempre y así por eso pues estos datos al final van saliendo y vas a analizarlos por encima vale
bien esto al final repito es zonas de trabajo pero elegiríamos los sets con esto no para operar no
por qué no por dos motivos primero ni con el mapa ni con este excel por dos motivos para uno
principalmente uno el dejarle elegir 8.000 como os he dicho antes es un ejercicio sobre optimización
bastante notables poco como lo que os decía de dejarlo variar los incrementos al final es un
poco lo mismo si yo le dejo elegir entre 8.000 in samples cuales van mejor y los meses que no el
data y luego me los ordeno al final esto esta ordenación que yo he hecho aquí aquí no está
en la zona 2 igual vamos a la 1 vale esa ordenación que yo he hecho aquí tampoco está aquí que ha
pasado pero pero que es que me está pasando se me han ido los colores eso estaba todo pintado no
vuelvo a cerrar tiene no sé no no eso estaba todo hecho todo estaba todo hecho con los colores
abierto todo tienes la selección y tal de cambiar la tabla no se me ha cambiado todo bueno
yo aquí tengo entonces pues mira que hay un 10 y un 4 hemos hablado del 4 antes hemos hablado
del 10 también pero teníamos dudas vale no sale más por aquí salen 4 a 10 es 5 7 5 bueno
está ahí en el límite que hemos considerado apto 6 7 5 estaría fuera estaría fuera uno
también estaría apto 0 7 también entonces son zonas operativas el 10 dudoso el más operativo
de aquí es este pero aún así si ahora que compara el sample con otro sample bueno pueden
ser los mejores o no no lo son de hecho pero pero este puede ser que sí si te está en la zona es
decir no son lejanos de uno de los mejores en sample es 25 pero no sample no aparece ninguno
el problema es que son 8000 entonces ahí nunca elegimos de este de este ser lo que hacemos es
hacer o la misma opti o otra de acuerdo que a lo mejor ya con el mapa yo he podido acotar y a
lo mejor podría mejor si fuera más grande imaginaos que hubiera sido una optimización genética
la anterior mucho mayor podía ahora acotar y hacer una exhaustiva pero como yo ya la tengo hecha
yo la he hecho eso de dos maneras de hacerla esta es la misma exactamente la misma exactamente
la misma la 1 es sin esta extensión porque ya la teníamos hecha si no la hubiéramos hecho con la
extensión vale porque está ahora viendo esto lo mejor pues sería hacer esto más o menos 29 para
que son 65 pero esto acaba son unas horas en ordenadores potentes horas pues el 12 horas
14 horas y 27 horas en el mío a lo mejor en el dedicado que es un poco más lento pues dura 15
horas entonces se podía hacer esta ya y lo tienes todo en uno vale pero bueno no se ha hecho se ha
hecho esta entonces se ha hecho sólo guardando 250 es un número que aún 200 si quieres 100
puedes coger perfectamente 100 y hacemos lo mismo pero claro aquí ya en el in sample solo
hay 200 esto nosotros hemos construido seleccionándolo con una función buscar pero no no no complicaros
hay dos datos lo explico para que lo sepáis simplemente aquel que domine excel porque esto
ya esto sí que si no dominas excel pues te olvidas vale no hace falta meterse en complicante la vida
necesariamente pero aquí hay dos variables que se comparten entre las tres hojas una es el test el
test se comparte sin equivoco es el test que recoge cada combinación vale y luego el romunes
también es igual en todas las hojas vale entonces buscando el número de test aquí ordenas tú por
el fitness que has hecho por tsi ordenas por tsi que es el fitness que hemos usado en este excel
vale ordenó por tsi y automáticamente busco con la función buscar de las borro abajo hasta
201 elimino las ante las y las otras 250 me quedo con 250 y luego con una función buscar busco
estas test en la otra hoja y me quedo con esas vale es bueno esto ya digo si no sabes ni de
qué te hablo no te rompes la cabeza pero que el que sepa de excel sabe de qué le hablo y con una
función buscar hemos buscado estos test en el auto sample y no el data y hemos eliminado el resto
por una sencilla selección así vale y ya está pero si no pues vuelves a hacer la optimización
entonces ahora aquí nos hemos quedado con las 250 es decir esto es lo mismo que si hubiéramos
hecho la optimización porque ésta es exhaustiva que no hay no hay un algoritmo que selecciones
son todas entonces las 250 que mejor te se iteran se han quedado y por lo tanto yo sí que tengo aquí
unos datos in sample unos datos all data all sample y los datos all data y los tengo ordenados
también por suma porque el auto sample está detrás y cuando pongo la to sample detrás me gusta
más usar la suma incluyendo el robe en el cálculo y por lo tanto veo cuáles son los mejores in sample
que como veis lógicamente los mejores in sample los mejores si son los mismos porque los que eran
mejores en 8.000 son mejores en 250 lo que cambia o lo que puede cambiar es el auto sample
a ver un segundo que me he dejado abierto aquí un poquito voy a dar cuenta que no me estáis viendo
estáis disfrutando de mi enorme atractivo esto es un algo que me extraña que no estuviese ahí
advirtiendo sobre ello no pero bueno no pasa nada estaréis despistados o se están contentados la
gracias que nos habéis dado cuenta pero lo que ha sido es que si no nos entiende entonces ya
ordenamos por por suma el in sample lógicamente son los mismos eso es obvio no el que es mejor
con mil es mejor con 8.000 y con 250 mil pero no la to sample tiene por qué me acuerdo en el auto
sample no tiene por qué ser el mejor porque aquí ahora ya sólo hay 250 y bola fijaros que tengo
406 25 con varios y aquí tengo no sé si exactamente el mismo no es pero por ahí andan
por ahí es evidentemente la zona bastante bastante parecida si vamos al data pues nuevamente son los
cuatro en este tsi son los los cuatro que hacemos nosotros en este en este caso no te sé que no
hablado de vol forward al final si os hablo de vol forward vale pero de momento de momento yo
normalmente en apolo solemos elegir así solemos elegir así por el video el mapa yo tengo claras
mis zonas y ahora tengo mediante all data pues aquellos sets que trabajan mejor en equilibrio
porque con la suma pondero sobre pondero un poco el robot nes ya que me añade y lo tengo por un
fin es que este si son estos y lo tengo por el fin es ese que lógicamente muchas ocasiones
en algunos en común pero no siempre aquí de hecho como veis no los hay no hay en ese común
pero en este en el ppc sí que hay en común entre los dos hay un poco de mezcla de los dos aquí nos
sale más el 25 el ppc siempre tira más para para el retorno recuerdo el ppc te tira mucho para
el retorno una cosa que nos gusta mucho que esto creo que lo enseñé un poco en la práctica lo
enseño también aquí que tengo mis notas está es la ficha que tenemos en el whatnot y aquí a modo
de resumen recogemos siempre cuando cuando lo hacemos con tres sesiones estos tres excel y el
resumen de las tres variables y el robot nes esto es muy interesante porque de un vistazo de un
vistazo te puedes hacer una idea de cuál es el mejor vale aquí al estar 250 de ser exhaustiva
en la mediana que es el valor primero es bastante útil vale y aquí también tanto en las funciones
fitness como en el robot nes fijaros que te paliza respecto al tsi el s es el que mejor robot nes
tiene de hecho no tiene ni un solo robot nes negativo ni uno solo entre los 250 muy destacable
su mejora 167 pero tenés pero es que su mediana es 86 recordar que tiene es igual a un sample que
bastante bien vale bastante bien su valor medio de tsi 2700 mediano su valor mediano 5 millones
digamos que incluso supera al ppc que es el que el que se ha optimizado en él eso como puede ser
bueno porque ha tenido más capacidad predictiva del autosamper salen sample ha predicho mejor
entonces en este de estos tres exes aunque vamos a mirar los tres ls es el mejor eso es lo que
os digo se hablaba en el curso de la supervisión de los fines de acuerdo esto lógicamente de la
supervisión de todos los protocolos decir este tipo de cosas también sirven para eso para ir
viendo con el tiempo que predije mejor a un tipo de sistema a otro aquí predije ese predicho ha
tenido una mejor capacidad predictiva del autosamper pero repito que miramos los tres es verdad que
normalmente a mí se me dice es un caso de duda normalmente tsi suele ser un buen equilibrio pero
también nos gusta mucho ppc y nosotros nos tiramos mucho por el ppc porque si tú tienes
cartera y puedes cubrir el riesgo con otras maneras que son monetaria exposición diversificación
retorno al final vía sistema puede ser un muy buen vector de acuerdo porque yo riesgo ya lo
controlaré vía cartera vía exposición y viajes a monetaria entonces el sistema puede ser una
manera de verlo pero ahí están los tres insisto ahí están los vale bien entonces nosotros vamos
a mirar estos performance report porque al final hay que ver el performance report hay que ver el
gráfico el gráfico me refiero el comportamiento de la de la curva el gráfico ahora de hecho
lamentablemente en las últimas versiones de tres lesion han decidido sacarnos una cosa que a
nosotros nos gustaba mucho en vez de evolucionar a mejor parece que va a evolucionar a peor vale
que era simplemente cuando tienes aquí una función fitness y le das aquí a guardar puedes
puedes decir expulsar exportar en excel pues en cnv puedes usar en un xml vale este lo has
probado alberto hay jaimito que me parece que es así que grafica un momentito bueno espérate
es igual lo voy a poner ahí me parece que no lo he puesto en todos creo lo puse entero
adiós perfecto pésame para tres session se ha colgado en alegría ya tengo los hechos me da
igual por antiguamente es generado en un formato que era de microsoft que te generaba un archivo
que pensaba que ese xml podía ser pero no tengo dudas ahora creo que no creo que no y si si el
html html y entonces te dejaba ver te dejaba ver pero este ahora se ha colgado y al generarlo lo
ha generado mal entonces por eso no sé no sé si está bien o mal porque lo ha generado mal
y sale aquí que está dañado entonces no pero pudiera ser que sí pudiera ser que esto el lo
abriera el el hc el hc el hc a las las guarda ahora es que yo tengo colgado perfecto gracias
la carpeta de los testes no lo abre pero no hace nada no si es lo que me hacía a mí
es no tapar tu café ni está el informe si lo sé y suelo ver perfecto pues a ver y si lo abre
bueno pues antes que nada por un html donde tú abrías los gráficos y era muy
exportado muy chulo ahora pues han decidido solo excel entonces podías graficarlo pero no te
grafica entonces te exporta performance report exporta los datos tal que está muy bien toda la
información que quieras pero no te exporta los gráficos y la verdad que los gráficos pues vienen
bien también bien bien para verlo a nosotros nos gusta mucho pero ahora puedes poner aquí pegado
que es lo que normalmente hacemos pero hoy por lo que os decía por el tiempo no lo hemos hecho
le hacemos entonces nosotros lo que hacemos es sobre esos mejores y recogemos los performance
report también de los sets que de hecho no solemos hacerlo así hoy lo hemos hecho así pero
normalmente no ponemos que es el set es decir le ponemos su combinación y lo mezclamos aquí
entre todos tratamos de no mirar o sea no lo miramos los vamos abriendo y alberto esto lo
expliqué en la teoría es la única cosa más subjetiva que hay en el sentido de que al final
alberto hace su selección y ahora mía tiene su selección aquí y yo tengo la mía todavía
no las hemos puesto común todavía nos hemos puesto como lo vamos a hacer ahora yo fijaros que
me he quedado con tres de los set que operan que eso tiene su gracia pero hay sets operando me he
quedado con ellos o sea esto es la manera en la que valoramos si cambiamos o no cambiamos de acuerdo
decir incorporando en la fase final lo que opera y entonces decido si me los quedo o no me los quedo
que aún que los que me quedo luego se consideran que no son aptos para operar pues entonces el
tema no vale de acuerdo pero así es como lo hemos lo hemos visto de acuerdo alberto ha visto estos
y yo he visto estos yo los tengo ordenados de menos a más trades no no es por calidad vale por
ejemplo éste lo tenemos en común veo pero bueno alberto me ha dicho que luego los set no nos ha
considerado esa que no se sabe si se los elegiría o no que no se ha considerado 10 0 6 1 2 también
lo tenemos a estos dos lo tenemos los dos y este 10 0 5 este no lo tengo yo lo tengo yo y tú no
vale y luego pues tú tienes varios como has elegido otros y demás bueno bueno esta es un poco la
selección que hacemos de set aquí el problema es que en esta selección fijaros que no se nos ha
quedado a mí no me ha quedado ninguno del 4 aunque esos que operan puede ser que alguno lo sea
alberto si 45 que esa zona es buena esta 45 y 7 es buena lo hemos visto antes aunque 25
estaba muy bien y de hecho ese no recuerdo mal es el que iba mejor podemos ver la curva pero es
el que iba mejor fíjate que se lleva el tp a 1 y medio y medio este además nos gusta mucho porque
no hay muchos los cortos cuesta encontrar un set ahí con o tp y aguanta lo suficiente este es
probable que aunque se salga un poco de la zona lo lleváramos a operar porque en esta zona
aguantaba bastante tiene 0 6 y tener tp de 1 y medio en cortos si realmente funciona que creemos que se
puede funcionar porque lo ha hecho se ha operado en esa zona estaría estaría muy bien y el resto de
seds ya digo están operando el único yo al final es cupido el 1 y el 5 el 1 es el que estaba en
alerta se ha lavado y el 2 3 y 4 se quedan entonces el 1 y el 5 pues se podrían sustituir por estos
que hay que ahora ponerlo en común para que por lo común pero sería el procedimiento normal que
haríamos ahora íbamos una revisión de estos en pantalla y a veces nos quedamos con más y hoy
me he quedado a ver nos quedamos con puedes quedar con 10 porque luego puede haber otra
fase digo verlo en pantalla conjuntamente y como ya os dije vía por folio de acuerdo es decir vía
por folio ver ya cuál le pasa más decir meter meterlos todos distintas combinaciones con tu
mezcla de por folio y ver cuál de ellos va mejor a la cartera va mejor la cartera porque a lo mejor
este es mejor por sí solo pero resulta que esté la cartera le va mejor porque diversifica más porque
esto ya lo tiene otro sistema que operas entendéis entonces esta es una un poco la
manera de proceder nuestra vale y hasta aquí que vamos a hacer ahora bueno vamos a hacer
antes decía que lo he dicho que lo iba a explicar y no lo he hecho a mezclar esto no lo he hecho
cuando he dicho de lavado se me ha ocurrido una cosa y no sé qué ha pasado que creo que me he ido
de tema cuando hablábamos y os acordáis de el tema de los incrementos decía mira una de
las maneras de mirar los incrementos entonces lo hemos hecho aquí no decir bueno no el data
yo miro la variación de este de este input entonces bueno al final voy provocando se
me queden alineados que sólo me puede variar este ahora bueno aquí 250 que va a costar más
vamos a hacerlo en el de 8.000 vamos a hacerlo en el de 8.000 vamos a hacerlo en el de 8.000 porque
claro hay 8.000 el más fácil es en todos no pregunta en disco la pregunta dicen por ahí el
reto vale entonces lo que decía vale venga vamos aquí le das a los incrementos para provocar que se
queden todos quietos excepto el que tú quieres si vas ordenando por estos siempre se ordena por
el anterior entonces ahora todos los otros quedan ordenados y el único que debería de cambiar es
este es aquí que no este no este es el que hemos visto antes que hemos visto antes vale entonces
esta es una una variación pero lo que te decía otra de las maneras es ver cómo varían las otras
entiendes que eso es lo que no hemos caído antes es decir si yo tengo aquí un número entero vale
es decir variar un punto del número entero como varía decir estabilizó todas menos la que es el
número entero que es el indicador aquí mira aquí tengo otro que varía el número entero
no varía solo dos trades entonces desde este punto habría que ver también el valor bajo desde este
punto de vista eso que te decía la sensación que me daba es que ese 0 0 25 era un poco alto
entiendes pero hay que mirarlo mejor entonces pero es bastante probable bastante probable que
volvamos a trabajar un poco esto a ver si lo bajamos un poco ya de paso volveremos a analizar
estos y como hemos visto esta zona la abriremos es probable que la volvamos a hacer con estos
dos criterios pero bueno lo que va a salir va a ser de este entorno que esto pasa a veces analizando
los datos pues te das cuenta que te has equivocado que la zona que has tocado un límite que tal es
así y aquí aunque esto lo revisamos hace unas semanas sobre los incrementos pues no se ahora
deciros por qué pero mirando estos datos yo mi sensación ahora mismo es que el incremento es un
poco elevado mira aquí tengo otra variación del corto solo ser el 625 y me varía nuevamente
un montón de trades estás viendo alberto no es me varía otra vez 27 trades es demasiado en la
parte baja no te varía más cuando en el en el en el que es de un número entero que es así que
menos no puede ser podía ser más pero no menos a ver aquí en la parte baja mira aquí tenemos
45 aquí en la parte baja bueno un poquito más que antes pero pero como veis estamos en menos son
11 trades y en 5 10 3 yo lo encuentro que puede estar una zona razonable en esta magnitud de
que son más 900 pero qué bueno es eso no cuando era antes 20 sobre
680 es un 3 por ciento no sé es no es fácil encontrar una pauta rígida pero es lo que decía
una manera que puedes buscar es ver que si tienes algún otro parámetro que va por número entero
no puede granular podía ir a de 2 en 2 o 3 en 3 pero no puede ir a menos de 1 pues ver ese
1 cuánto varía entonces ese como mucho ese es el límite entonces también es depende no porque
no es una media pero imagínate que es una media no es lo mismo de 4 a 5 que de 25 a 26 esto por
ejemplo en algún sistema lo hablamos quiero que lo enseñamos tenemos un código para granular el
incremento porcentualmente es un poco más complejo pero pero bueno al final no es más que
programación en variarlo por eso que varía más de 4 a 5 que de 20 a 26 al revés perdón que varía
menos de 4 a 5 y que se va haciendo exponencial luego llega a 20 y a 3 en 3 porque esto tiene
tiene bastante sentido pero no es indicado está correcto así pero pero bueno eso es un poco lo
que hablamos de los incrementos así que sí que da la sensación que ese es un poco alto y mira
ya que estamos vamos a mirar también los de 0 10 vale los de 0 10 y aquí tenemos este por ejemplo
0 10 bueno veis este está ahí en 12 trades está ahí este este este parece más razonable parece
más razonable 10 15 trades eso es que parece más razonable parece más razonable si bajamos
mucho de stop en aquí tenemos variación de 2 tics es son más o menos como el otro era 1 eso sea este
el bar 1 da sensación que está demasiado amplio vale y ese puede ser y probablemente es uno de
porque le saltas demasiado de cada y esto sin querer porque no se ha previsto los incrementos
pues nos ha salido que que quizá los incrementos de este input nos también y veis un poco lo que
os hablaba en la teoría muchas veces de la importancia de los incrementos normalmente
la prudencia de no pasarse pero que también lo comentamos es necesario captar las señales y al
final puedes pasarte y como todo tiene su tampoco es que esto sea una burrada ponerlo no sería una
burrada operarlo con este incremento ni mucho menos pero está un poquito justito vale está un poquito
justito y deberíamos de seguramente bajarlo un poco más o incluso hasta la mitad de 125 hay que
verlo vale pues a ver me decía y pregunta en el disco pero es para ahora a modo de resumen a
ver a marrugat a marrugat el excel no lo dimos el excel al ver el excel no hemos dado un excel de
muestra nunca dijimos de darlo al final con los vídeos no sé si subíamos material allí si que
había material en uno de los vídeos esto no había material de excel si ahora me me
estás matando pero me lo apunto yo es que a mí me suena mucho haberlo dado ahora me estás haciendo
dudar si no lo hemos dado si ya lo daremos para ya lo daremos ya lo damos pero un excel de muestra
ya ya y pero yo vaya en mi mente habíamos dado ya uno pero al ver al verlo puesto en el disco
al verlo puesto en el disco si nos podíamos compartir el excel para las actividades de la
plantilla entonces esto bueno plantilla no hay plantilla cuidado eso cada sistema pues es su
plantillo es al final esto es un excel donde aquí pones una fichita y tal pero yo en mi mente
habíamos dado un excel pero insisto mi mente tiene las capacidades que tiene entonces lo
revisaremos a mí me suena que en la en la o sea en la teórica que nos ha fijado ahí abajo hay
adjuntos en todos está el glossario pero además en alguno del glossario había un excel creo yo
creo yo pero hay que mirarlo hay que mirarlo vale amarrugat pregunta en el discor una vez
salto la alarma cual para indicaros con una estrategia conocida de parámetros no está rendiendo
uno a realizarse una optimización de todo en base a eso que no concluís revisando por dos pares
de ojos que haces aparte que un nuevo juego de parámetros irá mejor bueno sí publicando mucho
el tema sí sí bueno es que es que es depende o sea salta una alarma cual el alarma os lo he
mostrado aquí al principio no sé si a lo mejor no estabas al arro se me ha colgado el
terrestre se me ha colgado aureli y la verdad era bueno es que ese ese no era o sea era draw down
nosotros tenemos si hay veces que no sé si lo he dicho en el curso lo he dicho a veces en un
directo vale pero nosotros la mayoría de veces que revisamos revisamos sin alarma de acuerdo es
decir porque tú ya le tienes sensibilidad al sistema lo va siguiendo lo que te digo es los
gráficos y ves que no está yendo bien vale pero aún así hay alarmas en los códigos que es eso que
habéis visto que cuando salta pero draw down peor trade y peor serie de fallos salta un aviso
vale y lo vemos pero lo normal es que cuando salte ese aviso ya está revisado ahora queremos
implementar que sí que cuando hacemos una análisis tenemos dudas bajamos una lista de
trade en excel y eso lo enseñamos en una práctica y lo hacemos lo que llevamos la revisión más
completa pero ya digo normalmente antes de eso ya ya nos salta nosotros os explicamos en manera
transparente las cosas que hacemos como hacemos y también nos explicamos cómo hay que hacer algunas
que a lo mejor no lo hacemos pues porque no hay tiempo porque consideramos que no que no renta el
esfuerzo que con que vale hacerlo por para porque ya lo miro con este código que habéis visto me
entendéis pero aún así en la teoría os hemos explicado las maneras ortodoxas de hacerlo y la
que si tú tienes un equipo o tienes tiempo suficiente para desarrollarlo y demás pues vale
la pena hacerlo pero por eso digo que no os volváis locos con eso porque mirando un performance report
vigilando el drop down vigilando los resultados del sistema se puede hacer la manera ortodoxa de
hacerlos llevando un control de operaciones y que a partir de 30 trades ya os lo os lo expliqué hay
distintas análisis de estadísticos y también me suena que dimos el excel de eso pero ahora tengo
dudas y se pueden hacer distintas pruebas de evaluación y con eso sale pero de verdad
los que tengáis un nivel avanzado bien los que estéis en una fase inicial no os comáis la cabeza
con eso de verdad nos coméis la cabeza y basaros en cosas drop down racha de fallos etcétera vale
entonces el proceso de revisión de este sistema ya digo es un sistema que lleva mucho tiempo operando
y consiste en eso revisar nuevamente los mapas y no lo he dicho eso por cierto los sets que elegimos
que están hechos en una optimización que viene desde el 99 se miran solo en los últimos 10 años
lo ponía en la carpeta pero no lo he dicho no este performance report que cogemos no es de todo el
histórico es de los últimos 10 y si el sistema se entraría puede ser de 5 incluso de 2 vale
depende del sistema porque porque a mí yo ya he elegido yo ya he optimizado he hecho los mapas de
todo el histórico pero para acabar de elegir sets y ver me interesa dentro de esa muestra de
todo el histórico es decir no no optimizo sólo los últimos 10 años yo he optimizado todo pero
dentro de esa muestra el histórico me centró sólo en el último periodo más cercano que son los
últimos 10 años no ves el 99 son pues 25 finales la mitad y podía ser un poco menos pero bueno como
es un sistema diario que al final eso tiene 303 estas combinaciones aquí pueden tener 303 280
de ese orden entonces bueno menos ya nos preferimos que sea una muestra de ese tipo pero si fuera
intradiaria a lo mejor y pues lo haríamos con más con más trecho vale a ver y entonces una vez
salta la alarma realiza su aplicación de todo bueno si realizamos realizamos realmente hemos
hecho más cosas como os decía antes que por ejemplo revisamos el tema de los incrementos
revisamos miramos los miramos de los que están operando para evaluar si estaban rotos o podían
estar todavía dentro de una zona normal concluimos que alguno podría estar ya demasiado desviado y
ahí se inicia este proceso de optimización de todo porque se sospecha que puede haber algún
set fuera de rango ya no y de hecho se ve que alguno está un poco forzado ahí en el mapa un
poco justo de acuerdo que está ahí en la zona un poco justo porque ahí esto ahora no lo no he
querido tampoco decirlo porque no lo he enseñado pero de las últimas veces el 3 de grada mucho
es decir normalmente la vamos a ahora hacer para arriba para arriba ya sospechaba que saldría bien
lo que para arriba sospecho que va a salir bien para abajo sospecho que va a salir mal
para abajo sospecho que va a salir mal entonces los cuatro ahí están un poquito más más justos
entonces ese son son sets muy inestables y bueno pues ahí sí es el resumen en esta estrategia que
es una estrategia que operan en gráfico diario que lleva muchos años operando y que es extremadamente
sencilla o sea que es un sistema extremadamente sencillo el sistema de operar no son ni tres
líneas y digo tres por no decir dos vale indicabas que no hacias world for world para polo
alguna razón no así que se ha hecho world for world para polo el problema que tiene de hecho
tenemos pendiente e intentar e intentar hacerlo lo que pasa que en tres esos nos ha petado porque
tiene demasiadas lo que ya creo que ya os lo conté nos reventó entonces ahora hemos bajado
de nuevo que tiene buena pinta y estamos en ello entonces vamos aprendiendo un poco pero
pero porque tenía que ser más estrecha no me convence estrecharla tanto al final lo trucas
pero el gol for warren en este tipo de sistema uno es diario el número de tres va muy justo
vale hay que hacerlo sin gestión monetaria porque la gestión monetaria al hacer rolling la mayoría
lo cuentan por dinero y entonces se rompe sacado el drawdown no es comparable porque el
drawdown claro va subiendo va subiendo el retorno va subiendo el drawdown a magnitudes enormes
entonces digamos que no te el no sé si este programa lo hará pero el detención no homogeniza
los resultados bien los tomen valor absoluto entonces al final no se pueden comparar los
distintos periodos y más en un diario que mezcla muchos años entiendes entonces los periodos
en sample y a dos samples haciendo el rolling que va haciendo no son comparables y al final
da datos con para peras con manzanas entonces hay que hacerlos en que sea monetaria y el otro
problema que tiene un equity en short vale es que es muy inestable es decir te pasa muchos
periodos de mercado largo o sea encontrar una ventana óptima es complejo porque es un mercado
como os he enseñado antes que no es nada estable no es nada estable no no por
abiertes eso que lo tengo colgado entonces el short es muy complicado de pasar en un
world forward en un equity es muy complicado pero aún así tenemos pendiente mirarlo no sé si
albertos acuerda si alguna vez en corto sólo nos ha pasado no sé si tú te acuerdas el world
forward en corto te constas pero te consta que ya ha pasado no sí no miraré sí que lo ha pasado
seguro cuando operaba o sea cuando lo optimizamos junto que esto ya os he comentado antes el inicio
que lo hacíamos y así lo pasaba para que lo tenía más trades y entonces tiene la capacidad
de ir a los dos lados y adaptarse mejor pero así es extremadamente complicado semanalmente
complicado porque porque que un periodo tenga capacidad predictiva por el otro en el largo es
más fácil pero en el corto es muy complicado porque depende de ventanas muy estrechas y entonces
claro le cuando entra un periodo muy alcista se pone en modo muy alcista pega una pequeña
corrección un poco fuerte y como está en modo alcista no entra entonces bueno es complicado que
los parámetros vayan adaptando haciendo rolling entonces aquí sí que suele ser mejor puede ser
cada mejor en el ancho red eso lo tenemos pendiente de mirar puede ir mejor vale porque al final el
el periodo es mucho más largo entiendes y eso es lo que necesita un sistema de este tipo parámetros
muy largos o sea que sea muy muy largo el periodo para poder adaptarse no para poder encontrar todos
todo tipo de mercados con los parámetros que se muevan de manera distinta en todo tipo de
mercados porque al final se está moviendo en un territorio que es hostil para él no o sea esto
es obvio es obvio que un sistema de cortos para equity es una zona hostil no es un no es una
zona ideal de hecho hay mucha gente que defiende en no hacerlo esto es lo que declaró lo explicado
porque nosotros lo hacemos pero vais a leer muchas gente entendida incluso que te va a decir que no
operes nunca en corto en bolsa te lo va a decir mucha gente vale nosotros y no es incorrecto pero
yo vuelvo un poco a decir lo que te decía antes de por favor y lo que tú quieres hacer a nivel de
producto cuando tú de una manera u otra tratas de obtener rentabilidad para otra gente de acuerdo
para terceros entonces nosotros al final esa es nuestra intención nosotros es ganar dinero a través
de que clientes que operan esas estrategias ganan dinero y por eso yo tengo dos perfiles tengo un
perfil que es esmar beta y tengo un perfil que es ser alfa entonces claro la alfa es eso la alfa
sobre todo es batir a la renta variable es decir en es decir tener correlación pero cero o negativa
con la renta variable entonces claro si tú buscas alfa ya sé que cuesta pero meter cortos da mucha
alfa que tú quieres beta pues ya tienes a ser san esmar beta entiendes que haces entonces es un
poco depende de lo que tú quieras ahora tú estás haciendo un porfolio estás empezando olvídate de
los cortos en bolsa olvídate o sea no no es no es el sitio fácil no se ha insistido por él las
cosas fáciles no por esas cosas fáciles no es buscar cortos en bolsa no es buscar cortos ahora
tú ya tienes una cartera y buscas algo para diversificar tu cartera de bolsa pues adelante
a por ello vale pero no es la primera la primera cosa hacer ni mucho menos ni probablemente la
segunda aunque el otro día lo comentó se en que lo tengo aquí delante en él en él en el disco y
nosotros también en el rv digamos algo con el rv nos fue más fácil sacar cortos que largos pero
eso tiene el sentido de que es lo que se explicaba al final a los rebelos está escapando que pasa
aquí con con el tp lo habéis visto de napolo no que lo quiere corto lo quiere cerca porque el
corto necesita en bolsa operar rápido y salirse rápido en cambio un rv que hace hace eso en
sentido de bueno hace eso nosotros probamos un rv que cerrar a final de día ese fue lo que
intentamos encontrar entonces claro si yo te estoy obligando a cerrar a fin de día pues
en el lado largo normalmente está escapando mucho ronimiento es porque si va a subir va a subir va
a subir cinco días pues para qué cerrar a fin de día entonces luego hay gaps etcétera en cambio
en el corto es al revés eso es lo que le gusta le gusta hacer rápido perfecto pues es más fácil
si tú obligas a cerrar en el día con encontrar con roturas de volatilidad a gas tp te salgas y ganas
en corto entonces no rv intradía cerrando a fin de día es más fácil en corto que largo
pero esto no es contrario el otro justamente es lo mismo es es refuerza es por la obligación a
cerrar a fin de día entiendes porque yo lo obligo si yo le hago a mantener la posición dos días
completamente se invierte la tortilla entonces el corto le va a costar una vida un montón en
el largo te va a ser muy fácil entiendes es un poco la diferencia de dejar correr o no dejar
correr los cortos no quieren correr no quieren dejar correr beneficios en cambio los largos
quieren dejar correr porque el mercado no hace más que subir en el largo plazo de acuerdo nada más
a ver que me voy a apuntar dimos excels dimos excels tenemos ahí algún email pendiente creo
para mañana y tenemos también esto que han dicho de sí los artículos los artículos don chance
el día 5 de febrero esto no sé si lo has llegado a mirar o no lo pusimos vale pues
hay que amarrarlo disculpar que no lo pusimos pues lo dimos aquí en el disco en la clase y
no lo dimos vale pues pues hay que darlo artículo 5 de febrero y dimos excels en teoría vale nada más
sin más preguntas lo dejamos amigos que son las 9 y 18 3 horas y 4 minutos de clase pero
que se haya que os haya resultado útil es de las no bueno no es que todas de verdad
el rb también fue un montón de horas pero está esa también espero que os haya resultado útil
porque las horas de trabajo que tienen que son muchas más de tres muchas más de tres pero bueno
no nos quejamos nos vemos el martes que viene misma hora y ya sabéis cualquier pregunta en
el discord la verdad que ahora mismo no tengo claro porque he estado tan enfocado en preparar
esta que ni he pensado que después o sea que ya lo mañana lo pienso y lo y decidí empezamos a
prepararlo de acuerdo hasta el martes chao